Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
Die alten Malfarben, die seit 30 Jahren keiner mehr angefasst hat.
Hatte der eigentlich immer Damen zu Besuch, die er gemalt hat?
Ja, meistens schon.
Meistens, meistens schon.
Sogar, wo er mit meiner Oma schon verheiratet war,
hatte der auch Damen zu Besuch, die sich haben malen lassen.
Ich frage mich echt, was meine Oma davon hielte, gehalten hat.
Vor allem, ich meine, die waren ja dann auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Also keine Ahnung, stell dir mal vor, du bist irgendwie 50 oder so.
Und dein Kerl, der hat da irgendwie 25-jährige Mädels oben im Atelier.
Die Tür ist zu und die werden gemalt.
Ich hätte mir da an der Stelle von meiner Oma Gedanken gemacht,
aber anscheinend war das kein Problem.
Ja, aber guck mal, der hat auch noch eine Akte bei ihm.
Das hört er gar nicht mehr auf, Alter.
Guck mal, sogar mein Opa selbst hier, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Noch ein bisschen.
Noch mehr.
Das hört er gar nicht mehr auf.
Das bin ich hier hinten, wie ich klein war.
Ja, kleiner Max ist da auch dabei.
War dein Opa hauptberuflich Künstler oder als Hobby?
Früher hat er es als Hobby gemacht,
später hat er es mehr oder weniger hauptberuflich gemacht.
Leak, ja.
Das fand ich lustig, ey.
Wenn du oben durch das Atelier vom Opa gegangen bist,
dann hast du echt, das hat gefühlt zu 30-40% aus nackten Mädels bestanden, die Bilder.
Jetzt wissen wir, wie Max in ein paar Jahren aussieht.
Ne, so werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht aussehen.
Jaja.
So, mit was fangen wir denn an?
Wieder ein Stream.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent.
Ja, ich habe die letzten Tage ein bisschen Zeug gespielt mal wieder.
Übrigens, ich habe morgen gar nicht frei.
Ich habe morgen Big-Brain-Schulung, Azure DevOps.
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Aber nicht bei denen, irgendwo anders.
Eine fünftägige Microsoft Azure DevOps-Schulung.
Das wird, ich weiß jetzt schon, dass das wahrscheinlich
zu, mal locker zur Hälfte, extrem langweilig wird.
Ich hoffe, es sind ein paar Sachen dabei, die was taugen.
Die meisten Azure-Schulungen sind Hyper-Resonance-Lieber.
Ja.
Und das liegt daran, weil die Schulungsleute
nicht einfach eine Schulung machen und den Leuten was beibringen wollen,
sondern die müssen sich alle an so einem komischen Microsoft-Material abarbeiten.
Also sprich, die haben da mehr oder weniger
ein paar vorgefertigte PowerPoint-Dinger,
dass das eben halt standardisiert ist.
Und dann ist das im Prinzip nur runtergerattert.
Das ist übelst langweilig.
Wozu braucht man da für eine Schulung?
Eigentlich gar nicht.
Ums Papier? Nee, nee.
Also du könntest die Schulung als Zertifikatsvorbereitung machen,
aber ich mache kein Zertifikat.
Wozu soll ich ein Zertifikat machen?
Zertifikats Monarch S.
Ich mache kein Zertifikat.
Wie heißt du damals noch auf YouTube?
Tja, das ist die Frage.
Nur Oldschool-Leute wissen das.
Oh nee, jetzt verreist es.
Jetzt verreist es.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so,
als wäre hier ein Link auf YouTube.
Richtig.
No Bad Energy hat es verraten.
Was wollte ich jetzt da gerade sagen?
Genau, also wozu man da eine Schulung braucht,
das ist eine berechtigte Frage hier.
Wer hat es gefragt?
Dubstep?
Nee, Dubstaniel.
Eigentlich braucht man das gar nicht.
Allerdings,
wenn man da eine Schulung braucht,
sind die bei uns gerade so scharf drauf,
dass alle die wahnsinnige Escher-Kompetenz haben.
Und es ist egal, ob man da auch so...
Warte, jetzt wird es ein bisschen laut, die Musik.
Die können sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
So.
Dann ist es bei uns auch fast egal,
ob du dich damit auskennst oder nicht.
Die sind so scharf drauf,
dass die Leute gerade Schulungen machen.
Und unser Chef war auch am Start und hat gemeint,
ja, es gibt es jetzt aktuell reduziert die Schulung
und sonst was.
Mach doch mal eine.
Ja.
Da haben wir uns halt die rausgesucht,
die uns noch am meisten interessiert.
Und ich hoffe jetzt, es taugt halt was.
Wirklich brauchen tut man sie wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das, was man bisher in den Escher-Schulungen gemacht hat,
hätte man sich eigentlich auch in ein, zwei Tagen
locker selbst angucken können,
hätte besser durchgeblickt.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es auch wieder so ein Ding,
weil am Ende sitzen da ja irgendwelche Stonksleute
und wenn dann wahrscheinlich
der jeweilige Gruppenteam, Abteilungs- was auch immer,
Leiter sagen kann, bei mir haben 80% Escher-Schulung gemacht,
dann sagt dann der Stonksmann, boah, ihr seid geil.
Das ist ja hier, ja, ihr kennt euch jetzt richtig, richtig aus
und seid richtig, äh, exzellent.
Ja.
Und wer sich wirklich auskennt,
darum geht es, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Es geht eher darum, dass es gut aussieht.
So.
Irgendwas hat doch vorhin einer geschickt,
was wir uns angucken sollen.
Das da.
Wie sicher ist die Corona-App?
Oh je, oh je, oh je, oh je.
Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ist das Video Juni?
Moment, das ist einen Monat alt.
Äh, das kenne ich, das ist uralt, das Video.
Das ist überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell.
Mittlerweile gibt es noch mehr, mehr Sachen, oder?
Mittlerweile gibt es doch sogar schon irgendeine,
irgendeine Analyse was, was Backend-mäßig angeht.
Also, das ist doch gar nicht mehr aktuell.
Äh.
Ihr könnt es trotzdem gucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Ich bin ja mal auf den Chat gespannt.
Der Chat ist bestimmt voll mit
Monka-Corona-Sachen.
Also von Bill Gates.
Im Chat, da würde ich jetzt erwarten,
von Bill Gates.
Wir gucken mal kurz durch,
was da alles im Chat so gekommen ist.
Von Bill Gates bis sonst was.
Ich weiß nicht,
aber wenn sie nicht open soll,
ist sie doch.
Könnt ihr behalten, den Dreck?
Scheiß Stasi-Statistik.
Der Chat, Alter.
Wander doch aus.
By the way,
ich habe die Corona-App nicht installiert.
Weißt du auch warum?
Weil es auf meinem Handy nicht funktioniert.
Kann man nichts machen.
Das ist noch harmlos.
Ja klar, das geht noch schlimmer.
Nee, aber das lohnt sich glaube ich
nicht wirklich anzugucken.
Das Video ist einen Monat alt.
Es ist viel spannender, sich anzugucken.
Es gab letztens doch so eine Analyse,
was auch Server-Infrastruktur
und sowas angeht.
Die ist viel neuer, das ist erst ein paar Tage alt.
Wieso heute so früh?
Jetzt wird sich schon
beschwert, dass ich früher am Start bin.
Keck, wait.
Ich habe
letztens was auf
YouTube gefunden und zwar
Wie heißt das?
Twitch Chat
People Emotes.
Moment, Moment.
Explained.
Hier.
Ja.
Üst.
Üst, nice.
Das ist ein Video.
Von dem haben wir übrigens schon mal was geguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht mehr
mehr Viewer hat.
Aber von dem haben wir schon mal das hier geguckt.
Von dem haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Story of Lulwe versus Kekwe.
Das haben wir schon mal geguckt hier.
Aber ich dachte damals,
ich habe mich damals schon gewundert,
warum das so wenig Views hat.
Und ich wundere mich immer noch, warum das so wenig Views hat.
Weil allein schon der Anfang sollte dafür sorgen,
dass es 800.000,
Views hat.
Allein schon der Anfang.
Ja, okay, wir lassen uns jetzt.
Wir lassen uns jetzt von ihm mal erklären,
how to Twitch Chat People Emotes.
Hello.
Hello, hello, welcome back, class.
I hope you brought your notebooks like I asked you all to.
As today is a very.
Hello, hello, welcome back, class.
I hope you brought your notebooks like I asked you all to.
As today is a very important lesson.
So up to now we've gone over Emotes that have been brought to life
because of global Twitch Emotes such as Pogchamp and Forehead.
But today.
Ah, yes.
Ah, yes, GachiHyper.
Can I go to the bathroom real quick?
You had all this time before class to go.
You know what?
Yes, just go and make it quick.
Mon gratos.
Anyways, we'll be looking at the largest collection of Emotes on Twitch.
Today, let's check out.
Pogo habe ich nicht.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von Pogo gar nicht.
Ich finde das irgendwie total bescheuert.
Es gibt für alle anderen irgendwelche Pog Emotes.
Wozu braucht man Pogo?
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir das ja erklären.
Because there are so many different variations of this Emote.
Today's lesson will be broken down into the set of Pepe Emotes
that specifically have the Pepe and Pipo prefix.
The first Emote we'll look at is Pepehands.
Pepehands use can be broken down quite easily.
If anything sad happens in real life or in a video game,
this is one of the most ideal Emotes to spam.
One use that should be mentioned is that this Emote is usually spammed
when a streamer is ending their stream, usually accompanied with a
Pogo Emote.
Anyways, guys, I think I'm going to end stream here.
There really isn't much explaining to be done,
as this Emote itself is very self-explanatory.
Pepe Laugh is probably one of my favorite Emotes,
just for the sole reason that it is paired with this laughing video.
Look at the top of his head.
There are multiple uses.
Was war das?
This is Pepe Laugh, and there really isn't one that is more popular than the other.
Is the streamer playing a game and there's about to be a jump scare,
or the streamer has no idea what they're supposed to be doing?
You'll see chat flooded with Pepe Laugh.
He's lacking critical information.
Paired with a he doesn't know or he is unaware and the most popular Combo.
He lacks critical information.
Is when Pepe Laugh is used to roast a streamer.
Anytime a streamer is getting flamed by their own chat,
you'll be sure to see a whole barrage of Pepe Laugh spam.
This specific use is essentially low W,
but it's only really used when someone is roasting a streamer more than anything else.
Ah, yes.
Pause.
After further research
and me just being absolutely dumb,
Pepe Laugh is just used to just roast anything.
You can just roast whatever you want.
Mal gucken, ob er auch Peepo Planket hat.
It's not just a streamer.
That was my bad.
I'm a fucking pepega.
Okay, continue.
The next Emo I want to touch on,
because even though this Emo is enabled in 25,000 channels,
I barely see it.
Let's talk about Peepo Think.
Ah, nee, doch nicht.
This is an older Emo.
Haben wir das?
Haben wir das enabled?
Haben wir nicht.
Doch, haben wir.
Haben wir.
Old school Emo.
Jetzt habt ihr's gehört.
It's been replaced by Emotes such as Peepo Think Man or Peepo Special Man.
As it has a similar style of what its message is trying to portray,
which is just something really flat out dumb or stupid.
So if you find yourself in a channel with this Emo enabled,
be sure to show some love, because hopefully he probably needs it.
These next two emotes and their wide counterparts are a blanket
in any Twitch chat.
I'm talking about Peepo Sad and Peepo Happy.
And of course, they're more popular wide versions.
When using wide Peepo Sad, more often than not,
the gag is to also type like how a child speaks.
A prime example of this is...
Okay, hier kriegt man richtig beigebracht, wie man den Twitch Chat verwendet.
Ich hab Peepo Sad immer falsch verwendet.
... playing a story game and has been playing for a while,
you will slowly see chat begin to spam.
Please pee break wide Peepo Sad.
When typing with the wide Peepo Sad Emote,
there is a fine line between typing like how a kid talks
and going full ayaya.
Please, please do not go full ayaya,
or you will get barraged by a sea of nammers
and you will really be...
Weeps out, kommt dann.
... wide Peepo Sad is also used for an animal has died in a video game
... or for streamers watching a video
where a real animal is struggling or stuck somewhere,
you will see chat spam wide Peepo Sad as well.
Ich würde Peepo Hands nehmen.
Das, was man für dieses E-Mail benutzt, ist,
wenn ein süßes Tier im Stream ist, wie ein Puppe, ein Kitten
oder das eine Video, das Seel.mp4 heißt.
Und es gibt einige Worte über das wide Peepo Happy E-Mail,
dass sie alle den Underlord lieben
und eine unverzweifelte Blutlust haben oder über alles Leben.
Aber Worte sind Worte, richtig?
Für Peepo Sad und Peepo Happy
benutzt niemand sie besonders,
weil die wide Versionen viel populärer sind als sie.
Und die wide Versionen sind einfach lustiger zu sehen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Peepo Clap ist der go-to E-Mail,
wenn ein Streamer beurteilt, dass er deine Mutter f***en wird.
Dieses E-Mail wird gespammt,
je nachdem, was die Schule-Humor auf dem Stream gesagt hat.
Wenn das E-Mail gespammt wird,
ermöglicht es den Streamer, immer noch zu weinen,
wenn eine schwere Seele 3 Dollar auf ein Text-zu-Sprache-Message bezahlt hat.
Deine Mom-Gerüchte sind die populärste Form,
eine People-Clap-Spam zu initiieren.
Und um ehrlich zu sein, kannst du es nicht wirklich hassen.
Denn schau, wie wütend er aussieht.
Die nächsten E-Mails sind alle über Tanz,
und es gibt viele.
Also fangen wir einfach mal mit Pepe Jam und Pepe Please an.
Pepe Jam ist der bekannteste E-Mail für Tanz-E-Mails,
bis zu dem Punkt, wo Leute die Songs, die sie genießen, als Pepe-Jammers bezeichnen.
Dieses E-Mail ist...
Pepe-Pepe, wir haben was Neues.
Stimmt, hab ich gestern aktiviert.
Also ich muss sagen, mein Pepe Please ist mehr High-Rest als sein Pepe Please.
Es ist ein E-Mail, das sich mit den anderen bezieht.
Diese nächsten zwei E-Mails sind die gleichen E-Mails,
aber nur eine Disco-Version des vorherigen E-Mails.
Schauen wir uns Pepe D und Pepe Ds an.
Finde ich doof, habe ich auch nicht aktiviert.
Diese E-Mails werden gespammt, wenn ein Song, das man genießt, aufkommt.
Aber dank Angeku, der diese verrückten E-Mail-Musik-Videos kreiert,
werden diese E-Mails meistens gespammt, wenn EDM mehr gespielt wird als alles andere.
Die letzten zwei Tanz-E-Mails werden...
Overheat, Overheat ist das.
... vollständig koordiniert in ihrem Spam.
Ich bin ja...
Ich...
Ich weiß ja immer, was mit mir los ist, ne?
Warum erkenne ich die Emotes schon, wenn sie nur schwarz-weiß sind?
Also in dem Fall...
Ich kenne das Video schon, aber ich habe es am Anfang auch erkannt.
Das eines davon ist Pepe Overheat, oder wie das heißt.
... talking about Pepe Hop, Pepe Overheat.
Genau.
Warum erkenne ich das schon schwarz-weiß?
... Pepe Hop is being played, Pepe Hop is being spammed...
Painstamp.
... almost always accompanied with the word hold or chat hold.
... Spam will go on all the way until the drop...
... and the full unleash of Pepe Overheat...
... you will sometimes jokingly see people use Pepe Overheat with the word chat.
... I couldn't hold next to it...
Da...
Ich war letztens in irgendeinem Stream, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo es war.
Und da hat der Streamer gesagt, doch, don't POG yet.
Und der Chat hat dann irgendwie...
Danach hat er es wieder vergessen, ja?
Und der Chat hat zehn Minuten lang gespammt, I can't hold it.
Das ist so richtig dämlich.
Und dann irgendwann haben sie angefangen, alle rumzuspringen.
Can we POG yet?
Und irgendwann hat er dann gesagt, ja, now you can POG.
Und dann hat der Chat zehn Minuten POG gespammt.
Richtig hängengebliebenes Twitch-Zeugs, ja?
Aber deswegen mag ich Twitch.
Sag mal, kann mir irgendjemand erklären...
Ich hab mitgekriegt, irgendwie gab es die letzten Tage bei Knossi ein Angelcamp oder sowas.
So.
Und ganz Twitter-Deutschland hat das voll abgefeiert.
Und das hatte irgendwie 300.000 Viewer auf Twitch, so.
Und ich hab das zweimal angemacht, dreimal angemacht.
Das erste Mal waren das irgendwelche Leute, die man, also manche von kennt, auf einem Campingplatz.
Die haben auf Stühlen gesessen und irgendwie Zeug gelabert.
Das nächste Mal haben die im Dunkeln auf dem Campingplatz gesessen und irgendwie Zeug gelabert.
Und Knossi hat halt seinen typischen Knossi-Talk gemacht.
Dann war irgendwann Sido am Start, hat irgendwie zwei Sachen gesungen.
So, okay, also das habe ich davon mitgekriegt.
Äh...
Und irgendwie wird das jetzt als der neue Shit gefeiert, so nach dem Motto, so nach dem Motto,
Fernseh ist out, Twitch beste und so.
Und ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Für mich sah das so aus wie RTL, nur auf Twitch.
Aber ich bin da entweder zu alt oder zu...
Zu low-brain für...
Also ich verstehe die Begeisterung nicht.
Reality-TV für Zoomer, okay, ja.
Ja, genau so wirkte das auf mich auch.
Also ich kann die Begeisterung nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Es wirkt wie mitten im Leben oder so, oder...
Oder es wirkt wie RTL auf Twitch, ja.
Was, warte, was ist mit Sido passiert?
Der sitzt mit Knossi und wer ist noch dabei?
Knossi, unsympathisch, TV...
Keine Ahnung, wer da alles dabei ist.
In irgendeinem Camp und die labern halt da den ganzen Tag.
Ne, also hier, das da meine ich.
Twitch Angelcamp, so.
Wo ist das?
Ne, Quitsch Knossi muss man suchen.
Und ich verstehe nicht, was die da alles daran so geil finden irgendwie.
Okay, das Camp ist wohl vorbei.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das wirkt für mich wie RTL...
Wirkt für mich wie RTL auf Twitch und ich verstehe die Begeisterung nicht.
Na gut.
Aber, wie jeder wie er mag, ja.
Was war eigentlich mit der Geschichte?
Ja, Haftbefehl hat sich selbst angeschossen.
Das musste ich ja auch kecken, Alter.
Haftbefehl, Krankenhaus.
Haftbefehl hat sich irgendwelche Drogen eingeschmissen,
hat sich aus Versehen selbst angeschossen.
Da musste ich echt ne Runde lachen.
Das war echt...
Als ich das gelesen habe.
Rapper Haftbefehl schießt sich aus Versehen ins Bein.
Naja, was auch immer.
Irgendwie fand ich es lustig.
Doch nicht...
Doch nicht genug Gangsters da am Start.
Ja, wer kennt es nicht?
Wer kennt es nicht?
Wer schießt sich nicht aus Versehen in den Ball?
Ach ja.
Angeblich war er in Frankfurt, irgendwo im Bahnhofsviertel.
Das passt ja noch mehr.
Moment, was?
Moment, was war die Frage?
Ja, da gebe ich dir recht.
Aber es ist das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Eine Idee, wie ich meinen Raspberry Pi mit RetroPi starten kann,
ohne manuell Strom aus anzumachen.
Wake on LAN vielleicht?
Wake on LAN?
Oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Wake on WLAN?
Gibt es sowas?
Blöde Frage.
Gibt es Wake on WLAN?
Okay, anscheinend gibt es sowas.
Excellent.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Wake on WLAN?
Wie wäre es mit Wake on WLAN?
Was es nicht alles gibt?
Ja, aber Wake on LAN sollte so das Klassische sein.
Ich meine, du kannst natürlich auch sowas hier nehmen,
was ich mir da auf AliExpress bestellt habe.
Dafür...
Moment, AliExpress.
Oh fuck, wie hieß dieses Ding?
WF, Wifi, USB, Switch oder so.
Ach du Scheiße.
USB, Switch, WF, WF.
Ah, hier, da war es doch, WF.
Ja, den da.
Du kannst natürlich auch sowas da bestellen
und Custom Firmware flashen.
Dann hast du so ein Web Interface,
wo du dein Raspberry Pi quasi Strom an- und ausschalten kannst.
Das kannst du machen, wenn Wake on WLAN nicht geht.
Kostet nur 4,30 bei AliExpress.
Kannst du flashen,
hast Motor drauf und dann hast du ein Web Interface,
wo du quasi die USB Stromversorgung ein- und ausschalten kannst.
Kannst du auch manuell ein- und ausschalten.
Moment, wir wollten das Video fertig gucken.
Wo waren wir denn jetzt?
Ja.
It's still in the PP-Hop phase.
Other than that,
PP-Overheat is sometimes used
when something very fast is happening on stream.
For example,
when a streamer sets a YouTube video to double speed,
you have almost 100% of the scenes spamming PP-Overheat.
Now that we got the dancing Emotes out the way,
let's dive into everyone's favorite Emote.
So, auf Jelly sage ich gleich was zu.
After they jokingly compliment a streamer.
Let's look at Popega.
This Emote's primary use is if...
Bässe.
...or anything on the stream says something absolutely just dumbfoundingly stupid.
Because it's like three big factories in the world
who is polluting the entire stratosphere and like makes us die, so...
You will see the wall of Popega.
Ah, ja.
This Emote's breeding ground
are in xQc-Streams just for a sheer Popega farming capabilities.
And then you reach my goal, dude.
It's crushing because there's so much I invested in it
and somehow I don't get it to my goal, right?
xQc-Speaker.
Alright, so the product is not worth the fucking mental loss of it.
There are also a few variants that were birthed because of Popega,
such as Popega-AIM,
for when a streamer's aim is just so godawful.
This Emote is also mostly found in xQc's chatroom.
Man muss ja sagen,
man muss ja sagen,
Twitch international.
Ja.
Da ist auch schon ziemlich viel dummes Zeugs dabei.
So ist es, so ist es nicht.
Aber ich find, ich find das meist irgendwie noch
nicht, nicht so low brain lustig, sondern, sondern.
Es ist halt teilweise einfach wirklich lustig.
Ja, ich hab mir beispielsweise auch wirklich lang xQc angeguckt.
Ich kann mir den aktuell allerdings nicht mehr angucken.
Und das liegt weniger an xQc selbst, sondern eben am Chat.
Der Chat ist mittlerweile zu.
Zu gespamme.
Da ist, da ist nichts.
Da ist keinerlei Witz mehr im Chat bei xQc.
Das war, als er noch ein bisschen weniger Viewer hat, nicht ganz so schlimm.
Aber Twitch Deutschland entwickelt sich, glaube ich, jetzt eher zu RTL.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, hab ich noch nie.
Habt ihr das schon jemals gesehen?
Ich kenne das nicht und ich bin viel auf Twitch unterwegs.
Habe ich noch nie gehört, noch nie gesehen.
Was ist das?
Die kenne ich nicht.
Wenn using Pepe S, almost think like you're using Manka W,
but instead of it being used for a scary moment,
it will be used for stressful situations,
like this dude walking a tightrope across the Grand Canyon.
Also, wenn ich das sehen würde,
dann ist das für mich eindeutig eher Manka S.
... across the Grand Canyon.
For Pepe Meltdown, it is also used for stressful situations,
but it is also used when a streamer or someone a streamer is talking to
is just not capable of formulating their thoughts properly
and they end up embarrassing themselves by stuttering and stumbling over their words.
Oh my God, I'm so nervous.
And this is when you will see chat fully initiate their Pepe Meltdown spam.
Oh, perfect timing.
Okay, class, be sure to study up on those notes you just took.
Next lesson we'll dive into all the Pepe Emotes with the feels prefix
and also some miscellaneous Pepe Emotes, like Coggers.
Alright, class.
Coggers, Beste.
Viel zu underused, Coggers.
Coggers ist das Beste.
Coggers.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt haben wir die Piepe, Piep, Piep, was ist das?
Die Pepe Emotes gelernt.
Und ihr wisst ja, eigentlich geht das
überhaupt nicht, weil allein schon, allein schon Pepe Emotes zu verwenden
ist ja eigentlich Hate Speech, weiß man ja heute.
Ja, also Pepe ist ja offiziell ein Hasssymbol mittlerweile.
Wie auch immer 2020, Alter, die Welt hat sie nicht mehr alle.
Yep, Hasssymbol, ja.
Genauso, genauso wie das okay, genauso wie das okay Emoji.
Ich glaube, das okay Emoji, also das da okay Hand Emoji, ich glaube,
das ist der einzige Troll von 4chan, den 4chan jetzt selbst bereut.
Normalerweise, also wer das nicht kennt, mal kurz zur Erklärung, das hier
ist ein ganz normales Emoji, bedeutet in der Regel eigentlich immer okay,
also in ganz vielen Bereichen der Welt, nicht in allen, aber meistens
irgendwas Positives mit der Verbindung irgendwie okay passt schon, ja.
Und 4chan hat dann getrollt und die Presse hat es aufgegriffen, dass das
angeblich für White Power steht.
So, und nachdem sich das jetzt so durchgesetzt hat, ist für viele das
hier jetzt auf einmal White Power anstatt das okay Hand.
Im Prinzip ist es ein stinknormaler 4chan Troll, wie alles, wie
vieles, wie vieles andere auch, ja, aber ich glaube, das ist der einzige
4chan Troll, den 4chan selber bereut, weil es zu ausgeufert ist und jetzt
ein stinknormales Emoji auf einmal Hate Speech ist.
Arschloch in Italien, ja, passt ja von der Bezeichnung her, kann man sich
auch vorstellen, ja.
Also, ich glaube, das ist einer der wenigen 4chan Trolls, die 4chan selber
bereut.
Das okay Hand zu White Power umzudichten.
Aber allein schon, dass das funktioniert, sieht man mal, dass die Leute heute
ein bisschen Dachschaden haben allesamt, ne.
Also, wenn Pepe ein Hate Symbol ist und das okay Emoji auf einmal für White
Power steht und wisst ihr was, VWTF, ich rauche doch gar nicht.
Und wisst ihr, was das, was das Schlimme ist mittlerweile?
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich irgendwelche rechten Nazi, was auch immer Gruppierungen
es gibt, die tatsächlich jetzt das okay Hand Emoji in diesem Kontext verwenden.
Es ist, es ist Hardcore Monarch S, das ist richtig dämlich.
Als erstes ist es ein ganz normales Emoji, dann trollt 4chan und dann greifen das
noch irgendwelche Braindead Rechten auf und benutzen das auch noch.
Es ist so unglaublich dämlich, die Welt 2020, naja.
Motorize Roller Shape, brauche ich nicht, habe ich schon.
Okay, was können wir uns sonst noch angucken?
How to Twitch Chat haben wir jetzt schon geguckt, 2020 halt, ja, aber echt.
Slow Motion, sowas gucke ich mir normalerweise nicht an, aber das
Vorschaubild sah eigentlich ganz cool aus.
Alper HD, also Pepe, Pepe Love kann man nicht so verwenden, das geht nicht.
Da musst du noch dahinter schreiben, he lacks critical information, nur dann
ist das offiziell erlaubt auf Twitch.
Ghost of Tsushima Review.
Das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Ich glaube, das hier war das, wir gucken uns tatsächlich Ghost of Tsushima Review
an, weil da bin ich gespannt, was da rausgekommen ist.
Mal gucken, wer das macht.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, es ist Dimitri oder Maurice.
Mal gucken, wer das Review macht.
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Ann-Kathrin Cools.
Zu leise.
Grill Review.
Was war das, was war das?
Ein Granatenpfeil, alles klar.
Der fliegt ja auch so gerade.
Egal.
Okay, für Sibaro.
Falls ihr bis jetzt noch wenig von Ghost of Tsushima gehört habt,
fassen wir ganz kurz das Setting für euch zusammen.
Am Anfang des Spiels steht die Mongolen-Invasion Japans im späten 13.
Jahrhundert.
Ey, in der Mongolei, in der Mongolei ist gestern einer an der Beulenpest
gestorben, habe ich in den News gelesen.
Irgendwie passt das gerade zum Thema, ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass 2020 Leute noch an der Beulenpest sterben.
Sagen gibt's, ne?
Educational-Stream heute wieder.
... vorgelagerten kleineren Inseln, unter anderem Tsushima, ihren Anfang nahm.
Als Samurai Jin Sakai erleben wir, wie die Angreifer unsere Gruppe...
Was, warum, das frage ich mich, das frage ich mich bei Assassin's Creed Valhalla auch.
Was ist diese Besessenheit der Entwickler oder auch Filmemacher von Feuerpfeilen?
Was finden die alle an Feuerpfeilen?
So toll.
... Ruhe, Gewalt überrumpeln und die stolzen Krieger auf nur noch ein paar
Überlebende reduzieren, unter anderem uns selbst.
Logisch.
Man sieht sie, man könnte es einfach am Tag spielen lassen.
... Strandschlacht nach ein paar Minuten enden.
Okay, die, die, die, die Gegner sind ja richtig Big Brain.
Oh, das, ich sehe schon, das ist, das ist Gameplay, wo ich mich drüber, wo ich
mich, wo ich, wo ich mich ein bisschen daran abreagieren kann.
Guck mal, also, jetzt überleg mal.
Die Gegner sind...
... sind sehr Big Brain.
Da kommt die Kavallerie auf sie zugeritten.
Und was machen sie?
Einfach schön breit nebeneinander mit einem Schwert in der Hand warten, bis der
Reiter sie umreitet.
Excellent.
Genauso, genauso würde ich das auch machen.
Ich meine, Alternative wäre, sich vielleicht in Formation stellen mit einem
Speer oder so.
Aber nein, nein, nein, nein, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Strandschlacht nach ein paar Minuten enden.
Nachdem wir so weit zusammengeflogen wurden, dass wir wieder auf eigenen Beinen
stehen können, nehmen wir unser Katana in die Hand und machen uns auf, unsere von
Mongolen überrannte Insel zu befreien.
Jin steht dabei vor einem moralischen Konflikt.
Der Weg des Samurai ist eigentlich ehrenvoll.
Man stellt sich dem Feind im direkten Kampf und stirbt, wenn der andere überlegen ist.
Doch der Anführer...
Das ist aber, das ist aber ziemlich Low Brain.
... kämpft alles andere als ehrenvoll.
Er hat die Wege der Samurai studiert und verwendet ihren Verhaltenskodex gegen sie.
Um eine Chance zu haben, sich gegen die Übermacht der Invasoren zu behaupten,
muss Jin zu Guerilla-Taktiken greifen.
Geheime Attentate, Überraschungsangriffe oder Rauchbomben sind nur ein kleiner Teil davon.
Doch diese sind allesamt laut Jins Kodex ehrenlos.
Ist es an der Zeit...
Oh, kein Ehrenmann.
... seine Prinzipien in den Wind zu schießen?
Oder sollte er gerade in diesen schweren Zeiten an ihnen festhalten?
I trained you to fight with honor.
Honor died on the beach.
Ist das, ist das Hanzo?
Ist das Hanzo?
Moment.
Nicht Hanto... Hanzo Voice Actor.
Äh, wie heißt der Typ? Hier.
Ghost of Tsushima, wie auch immer man das schreibt.
Ja!
Das ist Hanzo!
Also nicht der Held, der andere Dude.
Wen spricht der da? Ghosts?
Additional Characters.
Irgendwelche Nebencharakter.
Das, das, das andere ist Hanzo. Hört euch das mal an.
The Khan deserves to suffer.
Also nicht der, der andere.
Der hier.
I trained you to fight with honor.
Das ist Hanzo!
Gerade in diesen schweren Zeiten an ihnen festhalten.
I trained you to fight with honor.
Honor died on the beach.
The Khan deserves to suffer.
Big Brain Voice Analyse.
Dieser schmale Grat zwischen Samurai und geisterartigen Guerillakämpfer bestimmt einen großen Teil der Story, aber auch des Gameplays.
Einerseits können wir uns Feinden im direkten Kampf mit dem Katan erstellen.
Das richtige Timing, geschicktes Parieren und korrektes Ausweichen sind hier maßgeblich für unser Überleben.
Zusätzlich dazu lernen wir mit der Zeit unterschiedliche Haltungen, die effektiv gegen bestimmte Gegner sind.
Die Steinhaltung beispielsweise hilft, schwer tragende Gegner zum Taumeln zu bringen.
Die Wasserhaltung hingegen...
Alter, was ist das für ein Riesentyp?
Das ist ein rechter Krieger!
Passend zum Samurai-Kodex können wir die ersten Gegner in einem Kampf auch zu einem offenen Duell herausfordern.
Das funktioniert per Quick-Time-Sequenz.
Wir halten die Dreieckstaste gedrückt und lassen los, sobald der Feind zum Angriff ankommt.
Ist unser Timing korrekt, ist der Gegner mit einem Schlag erledigt und wir müssen nur noch mit dem Rest der Bande kurz...
Moment, also der richtige Ayaya-Style wäre jetzt eigentlich gewesen...
Timing korrekt...
Also, also...
Er müsste jetzt eigentlich in zwei Hälften zersplittern und Blut rausspritzen in der Mitte.
Und, ganz wichtig, er müsste vorher noch irgendwie sowas sagen wie...
What?
Und dann...
Ist unser Timing korrekt, ist der Gegner mit einem Schlag erledigt und wir müssen nur noch mit dem Rest der Bande kurz...
Der hätte genau, Easy-Killer, der hätte zehn Sekunden länger in der Pose bleiben müssen, dann noch irgendwie sowas haben müssen wie...
What?
Und dann...
Und dann in zwei Hälften zersplittern.
...kurzen Prozess machen.
Ist es das nicht, bekommen wir ordentlich auf die Nase.
Auch wenn Jin nach jedem Sieg Entschlossenheitspunkte gewinnt, mit denen er sich heilen kann, ist unser Samurai kein Superman mit Haut aus Stahl.
Springen wir vorschnell in eine dichte Gruppe Feinde und kassieren zu viele Treffer, liegen wir schneller am Boden.
So wie hier.
Das haben wir natürlich nur gemacht...
Ja, es passiert ihm ja gar nichts.
Nicht, weil wir uns überschätzt haben.
Das kriegt er.
Bam.
Der Gegner braucht auch drei Stunden, bis er draufschlägt, oder?
Stimmt.
Hm, der Gegner liegt vor mir, was mache ich jetzt? Ich könnte draufschlagen, ich drehte ihn nochmal und jetzt überlege ich, jetzt überlege ich, jetzt überlege ich...
Ah, jetzt schlage ich mal drauf.
Big-Brain-Gegner.
Excellent.
Falls ihr euch übrigens fragt, warum ihr hier auch bei den aggressivsten Katana-Streichen kein Blut seht, das haben wir aus Jugendschutzgründen bei den meisten Clips ausgestellt.
Wie, was?
Tatsächlich fließt hier sehr viel Blut im Spiel.
Kein Blut.
Deutschland 2020, Alter.
Man muss das Blut immer noch ausstellen für Review-Videos.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Wunder bei so scharfen Waffen.
Das driftet jedoch zu keiner Zeit den übertriebenen Gore ab, sondern wirkt durchaus sinnvoll eingesetzt.
Gliedmaßen werden beispielsweise fast nie abgetrennt.
Die Blutformen zeigen aber Treffer sehr deutlich an.
Wer die direkte Konfrontation vermeiden will, kann mit Jin zum namensgebenden Geist von Tsushima werden und ein ganzes Feindeslager ausschalten, ohne dass irgendjemand bemerkt, wo wir sind.
Ah, Assassin-Wishen.
Dazu vergleichen wir das Gebiet der Mongolen, merken uns genau, wer wo steht und schicken sie einen nach dem anderen zu ihren Ahnen.
Wenn wir unsere Gegner aus hohem Pampasgras, von unter einem Haus oder aus der Luft angreifen, kommt definitives Assassinen-Feeling auf.
Assassino.
Da für das Mochilae-Jin solche moralischen Bedenken bereitet, ist er erstaunlich gut darin.
Mit der Zeit erlernt er auch hier neue Fähigkeiten, die unser Attentatsrepertoire erweitern.
Im Spiel haben wir die Wahl zwischen drei unterschiedlichen Schwierigkeitsgraden, die auch durchaus fordernd werden können.
Dabei ist Ghost of Tsushima jedoch zu keinem Zeitpunkt Erbarmungslos.
Die haben auch so ein bisschen dieses Assassin-Street-Slide-System, wo du von Gegner zu Gegner slidest, ohne dass du was machen musst.
In bestimmten Situationen können wir uns beispielsweise geschickt herauswieseln, wenn wir einen Rauchraum erfinden und uns anschließend im hohen Gras verstecken.
Stumm für den gleichen Angriff zu spammen, hilft uns aber trotzdem nicht weiter.
Wie oben beschrieben, treffen wir auf unterschiedliche Gegner, die unterschiedlich angegriffen werden müssen.
Haben wir die Grundlagen jedoch erst einmal verinnerlicht, entsteht ein mitreißender Flow.
Einziger Wermutstropfen.
Das Wermutstropfen ist hier die Kamera, die manchmal einfach in der Botanik steckt.
Treiben wir einen Feind beispielsweise in eine Ecke, hängt sie in einen Stein und versperrt uns so die Sicht.
Die fehlende Lock-On-Funktion macht solche Situationen zusätzlich kompliziert.
Denn niemand kann gut parieren, wenn er einen Felsbrocken oder Teile der Inneneinrichtung im Gesicht hat.
Je nachdem wie das gemacht ist, kann fehlendes Lock-On gar nicht so schlecht sein, weil wenn du quasi Gegner-Lock-On hast, das lädt dazu ein,
einfach sinnlos Attacks zu spammen, bis der Gegner umfällt.
So nach dem Motto, du kannst jetzt entweder eine geile Kombo machen oder fünfmal den Standard-Attack drücken.
Und mit Lock-On drücken die Leute einfach fünfmal Standard-Attack.
Oder es lädt zumindest dazu ein, also je nachdem wie das gemacht ist, muss es gar nicht schlecht sein.
Großen Wachs oder permanente Einbrüche der Bildrate.
Ghost of Tsushima erscheint zum Release in einem guten Zustand, erreicht allerdings nicht den technischen Feinschliff, den wir beispielsweise aus einem Open-World-Spiel wie Horizon Zero Dawn gewohnt sind.
Während die Framerate auf der PS4 Pro von Anfang bis Ende flüssig bleibt,
per Anzeigemodus könnt ihr den Schwerpunkt entweder auf die Auflösung oder eine freie Bildrate legen,
kam es auf der deutlich leistungsschwächeren Standard-Konsole im letzten Spielabschnitt gelegentlich zu Slowdowns.
Auch optisch, bezogen auf niedrige aufgelöste Texturen, müssen PS4-Besitzer Abstriche im Vergleich zur PS4 Pro in Kauf nehmen.
So affig gewesen diese Zwischen-Release-Geschichte.
Da sieht der Boden beinahe betrachtende Objekte wie Schiffe vor der Küste Tsushima's wirken etwas verwaschen.
Zum letzteren optischen Makel müssen auch Spieler auf der Pro rechnen.
Wir haben im Testvideo deswegen immer angegeben, ob die Szenen, die ihr seht, auf der PS4 oder der PS4 Pro aufgenommen wurden.
Neben gelegentlichen Clipping-Fehlern –
Oh, man muss auch craften, wie es aussieht!
– das Schwert blitzt durch den Umhang, mussten wir uns zu Spielbeginn mit der leicht hakeligen Kollisionsabfrage anfreunden.
Nach wenigen Stunden hatten wir uns zwar daran gewöhnt und konnten Jin Gekont lenken, zum Spielbeginn fällt dieser Punkt noch aus.
Ja, es wäre schon nicht schlecht, wenn sie links und rechts die gleiche Szene genommen hätten. Ja, das stimmt.
Zusammengefasst hat Sucker Punch,
immer vor Augen, dass es sich um ein aufwändiges Open-World-Spiel handelt,
aus technischer Sicht und mit Blick auf die Hardware-Limitierung der PS4 einen durchaus guten bis sehr guten Job gemacht.
Die kleinen Problemchen sorgen für einen etwas holprigen Start.
Im weiteren Verlauf des Action-Adventures bemerkt ihr sie jedoch nur als nicht weiter störende Randnotiz,
da die Spielwelt, die Charaktere und das Kampfsystem euch komplett in ihren Bann ziehen.
Denn die Umgebung ist ausnehmend schön.
Oh, das sieht echt cool aus.
Die Spiele sind sehr settingkompakt, aber trotzdem variabel.
Vom Strand über mit Pampasgras bedeckte Hügel,
Das sieht wirklich sehr hübsch aus.
hinzu vom herbstlichen Ginkgo-Goldengefärbnis.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist quasi die Sache für Open-World-Spiele, was sie als erstes immer hinkriegen, dass es coole Landschaftsszenen gibt.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal Witcher 3 von irgendeinem Turm an.
Das sieht auch richtig geil aus, obwohl das Spiel schon irgendwie, wie alt ist Witcher 3? Fünf Jahre oder so?
Ab der Tempelbezirke folgt hier eine malerische Gegend auf die nächste.
Je nach Tageszeit werfen Sonne oder Mond ihre Schatten
und auch Nebel kriecht bisweilen über die Map.
Einzig die Siedlungen sind bisweilen sehr eintönig.
Manchmal entdecken wir ein neues Lager und wundern uns,
weil es dem vorherigen so ähnlich sieht, dass wir schwören könnten, einfach am gleichen Ort zu sein.
Zwar können die ganz Ungeduldigen unter euch mit der Schnellreise Flux von einem entdeckten Punkt zum anderen springen,
das würden wir euch aber nicht empfehlen.
Denn zum einen sind die Wege meist wirklich nicht weit.
Zum anderen ist die Insel einfach so abwechslungsreich, dass die Ritte zwischen den Missionen schon fast meditativ wirken.
Oh.
Ja gut, heute haben die Leute aber nicht genug Aufmerksamkeitsspanne,
um zwei Minuten von einer Quest zur nächsten Quest zu reiten.
Das geht nicht.
Also in Zeiten, das müsste, das müsste eigentlich direkt jump-cuttet werden.
Quest fertig, bam, nächste Quest.
Sonst denken sich die Leute, ach nee, ich gehe jetzt lieber auf Twitch Angelcamp gucken,
bevor ich zwei Minuten zur nächsten Quest reite.
Mit den Missionsmarkern leitet uns hier der Wind.
Klingt ein bisschen nach Pocahontas, hilft aber tatsächlich dabei,
dass wir noch mehr in die Welt eintauchen können.
Dazu kommt, dass es einfach sehr viel in der Welt zu entdecken gibt.
Herummarodierende Gruppen von Mongolen, an denen wir neue Techniken ausprobieren können,
heiße Quellen und malerische Seen, die zum Szenieren einladen
und natürlich immer wieder Siedlungen oder Lager mit Geflüchteten,
die uns mit neuen Geschichten oder interessanten Nebenaufgaben versorgen.
Erwartet hier jedoch eine aktivitativ zugeflasterte Karte, wie sie viele aus Assassin's Creed kennen.
Statt uns mit einem Riesenhaufen Quests zu überrumpeln, sind die Aufgaben wohl gewählt
und dienen immer dazu, uns mehr in die Welt der Traditionen und Folklore von Tsushima eintauchen zu lassen.
Meistens gibt es außerdem ein Ausrüstungsstück oder eine Technik als Belohnung, die uns wirklich weiterbringt.
Folgen wir beispielsweise den Gerüchten über eine sagenhafte Katana-Technik,
die Blitze auf die Erde fallen lassen soll, treffen wir auf diesen freundlichen, inmitten von Leichen sitzenden, alten Mann.
Der erzählt uns nicht nur die Legende hinter der Technik, sondern meistens auch den Weg zu einem gefährlichen Krieger,
der alles dran setzt, sie zu lernen und jeden tötet, der sich ihm in den Weg stellt.
Als Samurai können wir sinnlosen Mord natürlich nicht dulden und setzen ihm nach.
Wie das Ganze ausgeht, verraten wir euch hier zwar nicht, aber die mehrteilige Nebenaufgabe hat uns definitiv bei der Stange gehalten.
Weil die Missionen immer wie sinnvolle Ergänzungen, anstatt sinnfreier Fehler wirken, wirkt auch das Spiel sinnvoll kompakt und nicht künstlich aufgebläht.
Selbst sammelbare Crafting-Items wie Bambus, Blumen oder Hölzer sind nicht aufdringlich überall und können sogar vom Pferd...
Jedes Game braucht Crafting mittlerweile.
...daus in Windeseile eingesammelt werden.
Das solltet ihr definitiv tun.
Denn mit ihnen lassen sich Rüstungen, Waffen und Gadgets verbessern.
Dadurch, dass Ressourcen relativ sparsam verteilt sind, freut ihr euch über jeden gesammelten Programm.
Okay, hoffentlich muss man nicht auch noch irgendwie Sachen kochen und Nahrungsmittel einsammeln und sowas.
Manche Games übertreiben es mittlerweile echt, ja.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche neuen Games, die einfach, keine Ahnung, eine Story haben und linear sind, ohne links und rechts Gedöns?
...Bambus und nutzt ihn sofort, um damit zu arbeiten.
Und damit eure Waffen aufzubessern.
Hier gammelt nichts...
Am besten jetzt noch Skilltrees...
...und XP...
...und die merklichen Verbesserungen motivieren dazu, mit offenen Augen über die Insel zu reiten.
Ich bin Sakai.
Ein Samurai?
Lebend.
Ich habe Nachricht von Fürstin Masako.
Ebenfalls merklich zum flüssigen Spielfluss beigetragen haben die Nebenfiguren, die nicht nur ausdrucksstark animiert wurden, sondern auch wirklich spannende Geschichten zu erzählen haben.
Während es natürlich Klischeefiguren wie einen einsamen lebenden Sensei...
...oder ein strenges Familienoberhaupt gibt, sind die Geschichten, die hinter diesen Figuren stecken, vielschichtig und meist nicht das, was sie auf den ersten Blick scheinen.
Wir zeigen euch übrigens aus Spoilergründen niemand wichtigen.
Einen guten Eindruck der Animationen bietet dieser Mönch aber auch.
Und auch er ist nicht das, was er zu sein scheint.
Aber warum, erfahrt ihr erst im Spiel.
Wenn euch viele der Geschichten wegen der Art ihrer Dialoge, der Dramaturgie oder der Inszenierung an alte Samurai-Filme erinnern, liegt ihr damit goldrichtig.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe noch nie alte Samurai-Filme geguckt.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
... und Sucker Punch Studios ließen sich vom berühmten Filmemacher Akira Kurosawa inspirieren, der das Genre nachhaltig geprägt hat.
Deswegen wirken viele der Cutscenes in Sachen Farbgebung und Kameraführung filmischer als viele andere Actionspiele.
Teil dieser Ästhetik sind übrigens auch die vagen Ladungen an Kirschblüten, Ahorn oder goldbrauner Ginko-Blätter, die in vielen der Cutscenes durchs Bild flattern.
Im Fotoeditor könnt ihr sogar die Intensität der Blätter einstellen, falls euch im Spiel noch nicht genug davon umhört.
Das reicht nicht. Zu wenig.
Gibt es so etwas wie zu viele Ahornblätter? Oder bedeutet mehr Ahorn nur mehr Stimmung?
Wer es übrigens ganz besonders filmisch haben will, kann im Kurosawa-Modus das Spiel in schwarz-weiß-körnigem Glanz erstrahlen und Dialoge und Sound so abspielen lassen, als handele es sich um Filme in den 50ern.
Ja, aber dann vielleicht mit nicht deutscher Synchro.
Nicht das schwarz-weiß-glas-Ding.
Wenn du es wirklich im Original haben willst, dann halt nicht mit deutscher Synchro, ne? Also das beißt sich irgendwie.
... wäre, dass Kurosawas Filme ausgemacht hätte. Aber viele seiner Werke erschienen in einer Zeit, in der das technisch das Bestmögliche war.
Wenn ihr also den Flair alter Filme erleben wollt, geht das auch. Nur die Ginko-Blätter verlieren dann natürlich ihren güldenen Glanz.
Spaß beiseite. Wir haben absolut nichts gegen die Ginko-Blätter.
Wo war denn der Spaß?
Weil sie, genau wie die Figuren und die Inszenierung, zur Atmosphäre des Spiels beitragen.
Und es zwischen seinen Genre-Kollegen eindeutig hervorstechen lassen.
Also...
Ghost of Tsushima wirkt zu jedem Zeitpunkt durchdacht. Und wie Games...
Also ich muss sagen, optisch gefiltert finde ich es echt hübsch gemacht.
Ansonsten ist es halt mal wieder ein weiteres Open-World-Game in einer Welt, wo jeder meint, er muss Open-World-Games machen.
Also ich brauche nicht noch mehr Open-World-Games. Das habe ich schon 20.000 Mal gesagt. Aber gut, man...
Heißt jetzt nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
... dass Rosso so treffend schreibt wie aus einem Guss.
Während das Spiel auf der einen Seite wirkt wie ein spielbarer Samurai-Film, greifen auf der anderen Seite Kampfmechaniken und Open-World-Aufbau sehr gut ineinander,
sodass wir uns immer wieder im Flow des Spiels verlieren.
In Sachen Performance muss sich Ghost of Tsushima zwar den Vergleich mit anderen First-Party-Spielen von Sony gefallen lassen,
weil hier nicht ganz das Niveau erreicht wird, das wir von solchen Titeln gewohnt sind.
Doch am Ende lässt sich leicht sagen, dass Sucker Punch mit Ghost of Tsushima einen mehr als würdigen Abschied von der PlayStation 4 einleitet.
Hm. Okay.
Exzellent.
Ähm...
Ich hätte gerne mehr Singleplayer-Story-Games zum Beispiel.
Mit ordentlicher Story.
Aber halt irgendwas mit rotem Faden ohne Open-World.
Übrigens, Sir of Jelly hat vorhin irgendwas gefragt, wozu ich was sagen wollte, habe ich ganz vergessen. Wo war das denn, Sir?
Jetzt habe ich mir nur noch gemerkt, dass der... Irgendwo?
Ein Kollege hat mir erzählt, keiner schreibt mehr HTML.
Und das ist alles vorher gerendert.
Hä? Jeder schreibt HTML? Wer sagt denn sowas, Sir of Jelly? Wer erzählt denn so einen Blödsinn?
Das ist totaler Schwachsinn.
Der Trend ist sogar eher umgedreht.
Der Trend ist sogar eher umgedreht, dass die meisten Sachen mittlerweile oder viele Sachen mittlerweile Client-Site gemacht werden und dort gerendert werden.
Server-Site Rendering... Also HTML ist es letztendlich immer, was hinten rauskommt.
Aber diese Server-Site Rendering-Geschichte ist eigentlich eher auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Ne, also das ist... Also ich weiß nicht, was dein Kollege da noch sonst zugesagt hat, aber es ist totaler Blödsinn.
Nö. Also das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Was der da erzählt.
Ist das PS4-Exclusive? Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, das ist PS4-Exclusive. Wahrscheinlich kommt es in einem Jahr dann auf den PC oder sowas.
Das ist PS4-Exclusive, ja.
Ja.
Hast du eigentlich Festplatten oder SSDs in deinem NAS?
Beides. Beides.
Ich meine, 12 TB in SSDs wäre ein bisschen teuer.
Ich habe eine 500G-Platte fürs System und ein bisschen was...
Bisschen Zeug drinne.
Und der Rest sind 12 TB Festplatte.
Klassische Magnet-Festplatte.
Moin, dummes Huhnchen.
So, was können wir uns sonst noch so angucken jetzt?
The fuck?
Wir müssen eine Runde Battlefield gucken.
Irgendwie müssen wir es an der Runde Battlefield jetzt.
20 Minutes of best Battlefield 4 Infantry Plays.
Excellent.
Hast du dir das HyperMirror mal im Discord angeschaut?
Ne, habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Was denn? Schick mal einen Link, wir können uns das hier angucken.
12 TB Games aufnehmen.
Ne, die Spiele nehme ich... also Gameplay nehme ich nicht aufs NAS auf.
Gameplay nehme ich auf meine zweite Festplatte.
Also auf meine vierte Festplatte oder was das ist vom Laufwerk her.
Hier in meinem Rechner auf. Und die Sachen, die ich behalten will, schiebe ich dann aufs NAS.
Das reicht ja dann auch. Muss man ja nicht direkt live draufschreiben.
Muss es eine Runde Battlefield geben. Das finde ich immer sehr entspannend, Sonntag morgens.
Hallo und willkommen zu den Battlefield Top Plays.
In diesem Video schauen wir uns Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 an.
Und anstatt der kurzen, nur in Battlefield-Momente, die ihr wahrscheinlich schon verwendet habt...
Und ich sage jedes Mal das Gleiche, dass er das Gleiche sagt.
Nun, wenn es darum geht, einen Top-Play zu wählen,
können wir uns danach angucken.
...schau durch und wähle einige, die mich wirklich erinnern.
Wow, das war großartig.
Und dann werde ich versuchen...
Moment, das ist Battlefield... Ne, ach ne. Das ist Battlefield 4 Metro?
Das ist Battlefield 4, oder?
Ne, ist das Battlefield 3?
Das sieht eher nach... vom... vom...
Ne, das ist Battlefield 3.
Das ist erstens... jetzt sieht man das hier am Blaustich.
Und an der Minimap.
Naja, weil er hier oben... Ich war verwirrt, weil hier oben steht...
20 Minutes Best Battlefield 4 Infantry Players.
Und das ist Battlefield 3.
Das ist... keck, wait.
Könntest du YouTube bisschen lauter machen?
Ich mach den absichtlich nicht lauter, weil ich laber immer drüber.
Und der sagt jedes Mal das Gleiche.
...maybe a certain theme,
or just break them down into the best clips of that week.
The last few weeks though have seen
quite a few of these longer Top-Plays get sent in.
And they can be quite difficult to integrate into a video.
These days people have short attention spans
and want really fast-paced content.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich bin begeistert, wie sich Leute heute noch an der Metro-Treppe abfahren lassen.
Hi, wie steht ihr so zu 21 zu 9 Monitoren?
Ist ne coole Sache zum Arbeiten.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich auch einen 21 zu 9 curved Monitor.
Das ist nice.
Daheim eher nicht, weil daheim spiel ich ja haupt...
Also, daheim arbeite ich und spiele ich.
Also, da ist ein 21 zu 9, find ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig toll.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man auf viel FPS steht.
Wenn man mit, sagen wir mal, normal viel FPS auskommt,
wenn man vielleicht sogar nur 60 FPS im Durchschnitt haben will,
dann kann man sich natürlich auch die fette Auflösung und 21 zu 9 gönnen.
Aber wer quasi 144, 240 Hertz Multiplayer spielt,
der kann das schlicht und ergreifend auf dem 21 zu 9 gar nicht richtig machen.
...because I know there are some people out there
that just want to watch the long killstreaks
and the super talented infantry players that we have on show.
Die Gott... bester Name.
1200 RPM, pew, pew, pew.
Klingt irgendwie ziemlich, äh, three hat.
...Battlefield 3 and 4.
Starting out is one of the biggest names in Battlefield 3 in Rusling Jimmers.
He's been featured in so many Top Plays episodes,
as I've said in the last episode that we watched on Battlefield 3.
This one is one of my favorites, the AN-94.
What a beast of a weapon in Battlefield 3 this gun was.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Aber nix geht über die M16 in dem Spiel.
...as sweetly as this.
The thing absolutely destroys players at all sorts of ranges
with that burst fire being absolutely nailed down by Rusling Jimmers.
A one-man-Army clip that goes on for around two minutes
with three...
...insane amounts of kills.
Und, und die Gegner sind wieder absolut, absolut braind...
Was macht der?
Was macht der da in der Eck?
Sitzt der auf dem Klo und wartet, dass der reinkommt, oder?
What?
What is happening?
What the fuck?
Ah.
...keeping it with some close quarters infantry action.
Next up we've got Matty,
a Battlefield 4 Operation Locker with the ACE 23.
This clip is much shorter...
Die Waffe ist extrem beliebt in Clips.
Ich hab...
Ach, Moment.
Das ist nicht die, die ich immer gespielt hab.
Ich hab die ACR gespielt. Die ACR hab ich immer gespielt.
Vielleicht soll ich's mal ausprobieren wieder.
...so many kills.
Boah, da geht's aber ab um den Trommel rum.
Das ist übrigens absichtlich, dass er so hoch und runter gesprungen ist.
Da zappelst du bei den Gegnern richtig rum.
Dadurch, dass Battlefield versucht, seine Bewegungen zu interpolieren.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht noch aus den alten Battlefields,
wenn du über ein Hindernis drüber gesprungen bist.
Dann ging's oftmals so, das Spiel wollte,
dass du quasi drüberspringst, Animation machst,
und in Wirklichkeit hat das Game so gemacht,
es hat dich hier gezeichnet und dann hat's dich da wieder registriert
und du bist hier quasi flipp drüber gewesen.
Ich glaub, das hat er versucht mit seinem Movement hier auch zu machen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das noch mal hinbekommen.
Ich lass mich aber gerne positiv überraschen mit dem nächsten Battlefield.
...with a 12-Man-Streak on Seas of Shanghai
using the SV-98 and limited HUD as well.
So the game looks extra special.
Battlefield 4 being a game that did come out in 2013,
but it could easily pass as a game that has come out
maybe in the last year or two.
So the game looks extra special.
Battlefield 4 being a game that did come out in 2013,
but it could easily pass as a game that has come out in 2013,
maybe in the last year or two.
Amazing stuff using the SV-98, killing enemies at all sorts of ranges
on this amazing game.
Da sieht ihn keiner!
Der absolut lowbrain-igste Gegner!
Nee, das ist kein Hardcore-Server,
da wäre er schon down.
Oh, dass er den gehittet hat, die zwei Kills waren nice!
Gegner mit der absolut brain...
Was sollt er machen, ja?
Was sollt er machen?
Er hat's kommen sehen.
Und jetzt durch den Smoke spotten und alles wegklatschen.
Der wollte ihn messen, habt ihr das gesehen?
Der hat gerade die Messer-Animation gestartet.
Lull.
Bevor wir auf den zweiten Clip von Christopher2JJ kommen,
möchte ich einen kurzen Schaut-Out an diesen Episode-Sponsor, Instant Gaming, geben.
Instant Gaming, wie ihr well wisst, hat diesen Kanal schon lange gesponsert.
Findet den Link in der Beschreibung unten.
Also auf den zweiten Clip von Christopher2JJ,
das ist wieder einmal ein 11er-Mann mit dem M249.
Ganz ähnlich wie der erste, aber dieses Mal...
Scheint beliebt zu sein.
LMG, Schalldämpfer und...
...in your face.
Die Gegner haben echt wieder das Gewehr falsch rum.
Ah.
Zwei Clips von Dark Fear.
Der erste ist ein etwas langsamerer, operationeller Schreibe,
mit dem AEK 971,
die Grenade in dort auch, um zu klären, ob es irgendwelche Enemien durch das Fenster gibt.
Und dann drücken, um das Delta-Objektiv zu klären.
Der Grund, warum ich diesen Clip wirklich mag, ist,
weil sein Team nur eine Flagge hat und die Enemien vier.
Man kann von der Minimap sehen, dass sein Team auch...
...auf alle drei Räder eingepennt ist, was es ziemlich schwierig macht, auszupassen.
Er macht einen tollen Job für sein Team,
durch die Enemie zu brechen, zu attackieren...
...und seine eigene Mannschaft zu helfen, in Richtung Delta-Objektiv zu schießen.
Gut, äh, äh, meine aktuell schießt er nur in eine Richtung.
Das kriege ich, das kriege ich auch noch hin.
Wie aktiv ist Battlefield 3 auf dem PC?
Geht, kann man ohne Probleme noch spielen.
Haben wir die letzten paar Wochen auch ein paar mal gemacht.
So, mal gucken, jetzt muss ja noch irgendwie der Top-Play kommen.
Also, da kommt man echt schwer raus.
Guckt euch das mal an, da steht ja alles voll.
Oh, Grenade!
Nice.
Das war cooles Movement.
Das war nice.
Natürlich G18, was sonst, ja.
A good map, not as good as the BF3 one in my opinion, but still great fun.
If you're on a decent server, it can be absolute hell.
If you're on a 64-Man-Server with nothing...
Also, 64 ist ja auch nicht spielbar.
...Shotguns, Claymores, all sorts.
That just isn't for me.
Denkst du, Battlefield schafft wieder ein Comeback?
Äh, äh, äh, äh, nee.
Ehrlich gesagt, nee.
Ich würd's mir wünschen und ich hätt's gern wieder, aber ich glaube nicht.
Die haben's so krass verschissen mit den letzten zwei Battlefields.
Ich glaub, die sind einfach, äh, die haben auch, die sind einfach unfähig mittlerweile.
Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass von Battlefield 3 wahrscheinlich, beziehungsweise, oder 4, oder Bad Company,
dass von Battlefield 3 wahrscheinlich, beziehungsweise, oder 4, oder Bad Company,
oder was auch immer, ist ja wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr da.
Vielleicht noch zwei Leute, oder so.
Boah, wie sie eben reinrennen von unten!
Wahnsinn!
Ich muss sagen, so schlecht fand ich Hardline gar nicht.
Woran Hardline gekrankt hat, ist, dass Hardline keine guten Spielmodi hatte.
Also, um's zu sagen, Rush hat gefehlt.
Alter, die lassen sich wieder wegsprayen!
Und ich treffe wieder nix!
Also, außer er.
Ich mein, der macht das schon echt gut, ne?
An der Stelle, das war wirklich Big Brain Move jetzt hier.
Ich glaub, das ist vielleicht gar nicht allen aufgefallen.
Guck mal hier.
Der setzt sich hinter die Kiste, guckt jetzt vor und jetzt siehst du gleich einen Sniper.
Ihr guckt, habt ihr's gesehen? Hinter ihm war ein Sniper.
Und jetzt geht er ein Stück rechts, dass ihn der Sniper nicht mehr hitten kann.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich guter Play.
Äh, Soziopathen-Max, ich bin schon lange auf Twitch am Start.
Auf YouTube jetzt in letzter Zeit ein bisschen weniger.
Max, hast du den Monitor auf 720p oder so?
Hä? Nee?
Ja, natürlich! Natürlich!
Wieder er! Er war's!
Das letzte Mal da auch am Start mit dem Shotgun-Play.
Alter, ist ja gut! War nicht nur Krach.
Das war übrigens die, die, die berühmte Battlefield-Hit-Detection hier.
Passt mal auf!
Äh, hallo?
Ja!
Das war, das war voll auf'm Arsch!
Guck mal!
Voll auf'm Arsch!
Mehr drauf sein kannst du nicht!
Aber Hit-Detection sagt Nope!
Ach so, ich hab 150% Zoom.
Warum?
Das kann ich euch gleich zeigen, warum ich 150% Zoom hab.
Really accurate!
Das erste, was man sieht, ist, der Headshot geht vorbei.
Jawoll!
Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte den jetzt auch nicht getroffen wahrscheinlich.
Boah, die hat er aber krass weggeschneibert, äh.
Max kommt jetzt, Alter, schlecht für die Augen.
Zeig's euch gleich, warum ich 150% hab.
Hold it!
Könnt ihr euch noch an die OP-Shotgun erinnern?
An die OP, äh, M-Dings-24-26-Dart oder was das war?
Wo du über die ganze Map schießen konntest?
Das ist etwas, worauf ich mich wirklich nicht begeistern mag.
Und es ist auch etwas, wofür man die Verteidigung zerstören muss.
Was ich auch nicht mag in der Medikamenten-Klasse.
Aber es ist sehr zu verwenden.
Wenn ihr es nicht habt, empfehle ich euch, es auszuprobieren.
Das Ding wird wirklich einen Lächeln auf euren Gesicht geben.
Ist das Spanisch?
Oder Italienisch?
Eher Italienisch, ja?
Oder Spanisch?
Oder Italienisch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Nee, eher Spanisch.
Eher Spanisch.
Ist das F2000?
Oh, die Gegner!
Bäm!
Oh nee, die Gegner sind schon tot, bevor die Granate explodiert.
Das ist ja doof.
Italienisch, okay.
F2000 wird nicht viel gespielt.
Ah, wenigstens Red Star.
Piep.
Dieser Jump-Reflex, den hab ich heute noch.
Wenn ein Gegner auf mich zukommt, erstmal jumpen.
Am besten hinter irgendeine Kiste oder eine Ecke.
Ja, diesen Jump-Reflex, ich weiß auch nicht.
Das ist so was, das hat man sich angewöhnt.
Hä?
Was war an der Decke?
Da hängt ein Gasrohr.
Ja, aber warum sollte man da dran schießen?
Okay, Crash Fluffy plus Invalorant.
Es ist, glaube ich, nicht gut, um die Ecke zu springen, ne?
Wegen Accuracy.
Ja, aber das ist doch gut.
Das ist doch gut.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, nice.
Ich bin ja begeistert, dass es Leute gibt, die Battlefield 3 streamen, so richtig, richtig
serious mit Facecam und allem.
Krasser Shit, ey.
Ja.
Die Gegner checken nichts, aber das ist cool zu sehen.
Ich finde so Clips, die einfach 45 Minuten permanentes Weggebashe sind, ich hab das lieber
als irgendwelche aus dem Jet springen, RPG Crossbow auf den gegnerischen Heli und dann
wieder in Chat springen.
So cool die Dinger sind, sowas guck ich mir lieber an.
Und er wird natürlich garantiert geflamed, weil Shotgun Noob.
Sobald du Shotgun verwendest, egal wie gut du bist, bist du quasi laut Chat immer Noob.
Ne, das ist nicht Battlefield 4, das ist Battlefield 3.
Das ist Battlefield 3.
Pustelsaft.
Das ist Battlefield 4.
Oh, nice Headshot!
Warte, das war keiner?!
Bam.
Facebewerbung ist raus.
Warum?
Ich wollte grad sagen, warum kriegen die den nicht tot?
Habe ich auch so viel nicht gespielt in dem Game, aber ich habe halt den Medic-Train hochgehalten.
Kennst du noch Zerka?
Hm, sagt mir gerade nichts.
Oh, und grausgerechte Claymore!
Ja, OP.
Ja, die G18 ist echt OP. Das Ding ist besser als der SMG.
Das Ding ist besser als der SMG.
Gibt es...
Gibt es die eigentlich als Single-Fire, die G18?
Gibt es die eigentlich als Single-Fire?
Oder hat er die auf Single-Fire sogar?
Ne, ne, der hat die auf Auto.
Du kannst die auf Single-Fire umstellen. Gut, warum sollte man das machen, ne?
Du kannst die auf Auto umstellen. Gut, warum sollte man das machen, ne?
Ich könnte sie auch auf Slow-Face machen, aber die G18 fällt nicht auf das Spiel.
Ich fand's gar nicht so schlecht. Klar, du hattest in Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 schon übelst OP-Sachen, aber du konntest...
Meine absolute Lieblingswaffe übrigens in dem Game. Aber du konntest gerade in Battlefield 3 Rush oder auch Battlefield 4 Rush, du konntest sehr viel über Position und Movement machen.
Und egal, du konntest die schlechteste Waffe der Welt spielen, wenn du nebenan den Gegnern standest und die in die andere Richtung geguckt haben.
Das ist wirklich ein guter Trick.
Die 18 Akimbo, ja, aber das war ein anderes Game
Moment, der Defi piept
Am Anfang
Battlefield Play for Free, hab ich nie gespielt
Das war in dieser Battlefield 2
Verschnitt
In your ass, Alter
Die checken es wieder nicht
Die haben es ja null gecheckt
Alle Spiele auf Deutsch
Der Rächerbonus
VfB
Ich gucke ja auch nur Video
Man erkennt sofort, dass Battlefield 3 ist
Ne, blaust dich extrem
Und die Perks unten
Sehr gut, jeder Mann
Pock
Oh
Oh, der war gut
Der war gut
Dass er den erwischt hat in einer Kiste ist nicht schlecht
Guck mal hier
Der guckt kaum raus
Also den mal so einfach so kurz drauf zu aimen
Und zu treppen, das ist nicht schlecht
Das war ziemlich
Pock like this hier
Dieser fette Red Dot beim Sniper
Oh
Okay, der ist
Oh, geil
Okay, die rennen ihm auch krass rein
Aber trotzdem
Das ist echt gut
Das ist echt ein guter Clip
Und dann killt er auch noch Leute mit der
Was ist denn das, eine USP, keine Ahnung
Krass
Das ist ein echt, das ist ein wirklich guter Clip
Nicht sterben
Ach, der lebt
Ich dachte, das wäre eine Leiche, die am Zug liegt
Der wird gehittet und hat auch keinen Bock sich zu bewegen
Egal, hat eh keinen Sinn mehr
Nope
Ja
Schreckt
Oh, wieder voll mit dem Kopf reinschrecken?
Der ist reingerannt
Das ist ein echt geiler Clip
Und jetzt macht er sogar noch, naja, nicht Legehennen, äh Capture-Henne
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee
Jetzt stirbt er
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Oh, äh, hä?
Moment, what, what, what the fuck?
Haben die sich gerade gegenseitig gemessert?
Hahaha
Die messern sich gerade gegenseitig
Das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen
Ah, herzerblatt
Oh, oh, Reds
Suppression, lul
Oh, nice
Und dann auch noch ein Headshot
Okay, das war Glück, aber trotzdem pock
Jetzt einfach mal wild
Oh, da war was
Einfach mal wild in Smoke schießen
Das ist ja ein mega geiler Clip
Jetzt wird er übermüdig
Jetzt wird er übermüdig hier
Aber huge, huge Clip
Nice
Pockers
So, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Ich habe 30 Milliarden Videos hier
So, Mo
Do old viruses work on modern PCs?
Okay
Speed up Windows
Oh, nee, nee, das will ich mir nicht angucken
Fünf Dinge, die man mit seinem Router-USB-Port machen kann
Okay, fünf Dinge
Den USB-Stick anschließen und es als
Ultra-Crap-NAS verwenden
Also warum 150%?
Ich glaube, ich habe es gar nicht auf 150% hier
Doch, ähm, weil
Man dann so im Fullscreen
Das komplette Video hat, inklusive dem Titel
Das фак 150%
Das fac 150%
Im, im, im
Breiten, im Theaterview, dann hat man das komplett
komplette Video und halt nur den Titel und
deswegen habe ich 150%.
Excellent.
Battlefield 3 startet nicht.
Wenn du
also ich weiß nicht
ob du nicht nur auf die Server joinen
kannst, weil das liegt manchmal
daran, dass Punkbuster nicht läuft.
Okay, was kann man
was kann man
für 5 coole Sachen mit seinem
Routerport machen? Kann du USB-Stick
anschließend absolut crap
nass verwenden?
Man kann vielleicht
Firmware-Updates machen über einen USB-Port.
Vielleicht, vielleicht einen Drucker anschließen.
Mehr fällt mir nicht ein.
Zeig mal her. Was kann man mit seinem
Routerport machen?
Router? Moment. Die coolen Leute sagen
Router. Router. Router.
What the hell? Fuck.
Was? What is happening?
Sellout-Modus
aktiv, activated.
Ja.
Da wäre ich auch drauf komme.
Okay. Ah, wir müssen uns das Video nicht
angucken.
Guck mal. Der hat, der hat Dings. Wir müssen
das Video gar nicht gucken. Okay, drucken.
Nass.
Mediaserver. Okay, das kommt aufs Gleiche raus.
Backup. Kommt auch aufs Gleiche
raus. Connectivity.
Das sind, das sind billig
TP-Link-Access-Point. Die sehen so aus.
Und das ist ein Dings,
ein Netgear.
Ach so, dass man Modem anschließt, meinte er damit.
Firmware-Updates.
Excellent. Gut, wir mussten das Video nicht
gucken. Wir wissen es, was er macht. Er druckt.
Er macht nass. Er macht,
Firmware-Updates und erschließt ein Modem an.
Excellent.
Siehst du? Ganz einfach, ohne das Video zu gucken.
What happened
to the all-female
League of Legends? Stimmt.
Was ist eigentlich aus denen geworden?
Vielleicht kann sich da noch irgendeiner dran erinnern.
Es gab
in der, ich verfolge LOL
nicht so sehr, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Deswegen kann es sein, dass ich jetzt Mist
erzähle, welche League, welche Leaks
das waren.
Aber es gab, es gibt ja wohl eine offizielle
League of Legends
Liga-Format.
So ein bisschen wie OWL wahrscheinlich.
Und
soweit ich weiß,
gab es dort als einziges
ein Female-Team.
Also ein komplettes Team aus Mädels.
Und auch nur,
weil die
Orga, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
zusammenkriege, also dort,
wo die quasi,
eingestellt waren,
die hat ihr altes LOL-Team
entlassen.
Und
die wollten da einen Werbe-Gag machen
und haben
ein All-Female-Team eingestellt.
Und die haben komplett
abgekackt.
Die waren mega schlecht.
Also, nein, das stimmt nicht.
Die waren nicht mega schlecht,
insgesamt gesehen. Die waren mega schlecht in dieser
Liga, wo halt richtig
viele gute Leute drin waren.
Ähm.
Und die waren, glaube ich, so schlecht,
dass die, die ersten Games
nicht mal einen Turm kaputt gekriegt
haben.
This video is sponsored by
ExpressVPN.
The year is 2011
and Riot Games is hosting the first ever
League of Legends World Championship.
The event only had a couple
hundred spectators present and garnered
over 200.000 viewers
watching live. And the prize pool of
such event was 100.000
aza.
Genau, das war das Team mit den
Support-Spieler, richtig.
Das darf man, man kann LoL
so sehr haten, wie man will, das war
neben CS eine der
somit Wegbereiter
der Sache.
LoL ist Toxic Shit,
jedes
Multiplayer-Spiel mit PvP ist Toxic
Shit, guckt ihr auf, ob man es rankt an,
viel schlimmer kann es auch nicht kommen.
Die meisten Mädels haben sich einfach nicht dafür interessiert.
Solange die nicht auf die Idee kommen,
da jetzt auch irgendeine Quote einzuführen oder so.
Because the exclusion of
women in esports actually ended
up spawning teams that would entice
entirely consist of women.
The goal in LoL of these teams is to prove
that girl gamers are just as good
as the boys. This is
their words, not mine. But how could
they prove this when some of these teams
would barely compete in anything
as professional players? These
teams aren't participating in any
established leagues or tournaments.
Instead, taking a look at a team like
PandaCute, an all-female team from
Hong Kong sponsored by Razer,
they specifically only competed
against other random female
teams.
Naja, gut.
Das ist ja auch mehr Werbegag
für den Sponsor.
Es ist eigentlich
genau das Entgegengesetzte,
was
viele Mädels, glaube ich,
erreichen wollen. So nach dem Motto, sie werden
nur eingestellt, nicht weil sie gut
spielen, sondern in dem Fall,
weil es ein guter
Werbedeal ist im Endeffekt.
Would these all-female
teams be able to prove
anything? But all this would
change in 2018
with Veivictis Esports.
Ach, genau so hieß die, ja, ich kann mich
wieder dran erinnern.
The Russian equivalent of the
LCS. This was just a regular
Esports team. It was entirely
comprised of male players.
But at one point it seemed that the
organization was struggling to fund
their professional team. They dropped
all their players and put up their franchise
lot up for sale.
Und es wollte keiner kaufen.
No one got it.
Es hat keiner gekauft und daraufhin haben sie sich
ein Female-Team geholt. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
This would force the
org to still participate
in the league, despite the fact
that they already threw away all their
players. So apparently the
only logical solution
was to create a brand new team
consisting of female players.
Now, regardless of
how bizarre the situation was,
this decision would create
a dynamic which until now
had never existed.
For the first time ever, a team fully
comprised of female players would be
competing in a tournament officially
organized by Riot Games.
War das nicht die, die da auch irgendwie fünfmal
Support gespielt haben oder so?
This meant that despite how unlikely it would be,
there was actually a statistical
chance that an all-female team
could make it to Worlds, the highest
level of competitive League of Legends.
Das war theoretisch. Theoretisch ist
die Chance da, ja, aber dazu hätten sie was
gewinnen müssen.
Genau, die Gegner haben, stimmt,
die Gegner haben Supports
gebannt, war das nicht das, wo
sogar ein Team Verwarnung bekommen
hat?
War das nicht sogar das, wo ein Team
eine Verwarnung bekommen hat, weil sie
die Charaktere der Gegner gebannt
haben oder sowas? Da war doch was,
das war schon ein paar Jahre her, ich kann mich da dunkel
dran erinnern.
But in some alternate universe
Faker is crying because he lost
to a player named Triggered.
The story of Veivictus
plays out like a movie or a show,
that starts off by telling you
how the story ends. You just
don't know how they're gonna get there.
And I say this because after participating
in two splits of the LCL,
they were officially removed
from the tournament.
So let's rewind and ask the big
question.
What happened?
Let's begin on
day one, February 16,
2019. The inaugural
match of the all-female
Veivictus eSports.
Ah, gecommeret!
They lost 12-1. However, tomorrow
they play again and will have another chance
at proving themselves.
Post-match thread.
Veivictus eSports vs. Vega Squadron.
31 minutes, 37
seconds. 52
to 2.
I've seen people get a 14-day suspension.
Sind das, Leute, mal,
sind das die Kills?
Sind das die Kills?
52 zu 2?
Ach du Schei...
So viele Kills haben die meisten Games nicht, oder?
Wie viele Kills haben die meisten Games?
20?
20, 25 vielleicht?
Ja. Ich kenn mich nur ganz am Rande
aus mit LOL, ja. Aber...
What the fuck? Die haben halt mega
auf den Sack gekriegt. Oder nee, gut,
in dem Fall auf den Sack kann man da nicht sagen, aber
sprichwörtlich kann man das sagen, ja.
... suspension for less.
Me and the boys. Smurfing in
iron. If I had this KDA
in a ranked game, I would be banned.
My girls
almost had them. Draft was
slightly off, but it's a good progress.
Next time.
For those who aren't entirely League of Legends
savvy, a score of
52 to 2 is horrible.
With no exceptions.
With a disastrous opening game,
Veivictus Gaming instantly became a meme
within the League of Legends community.
The English-speaking world
would generally have no reason to care
about the Russian professional scene.
Performances in Russia would barely
ever get traction on the League of Legends
subreddit. But there would be a
thread created for each and every
single match of Veivictus Gaming.
Now of course, not
all of these threads were that popular.
After the first couple headlines, people
got the message. There's a pro
team in Russia consisting of all
female players, and they
suck. So over time
this became old news and people
moved on. Until one month
after their infamous debut,
they would make headlines again.
This time because Veivictus
Esports broke a record.
The record for the fastest
defeat in the LCL.
Moment, dazu gibt's ein Rekord?
Third 2019, Veivictus
Esports lost a game of professional
League of Legends
in 13 minutes.
To put that into perspective,
an average game of League is
about 30 minutes long.
Additionally, in order to surrender,
Warum gibt es denn ein Rekord dafür?
Das ist ja ein Rekord.
Das ist ja ein Negativ-Rekord.
Die hätten, die hätten
den anderen den Rekord geben sollen
für fastest win, aber doch nicht
fastest loss.
Esports has a joke.
Also, if you know anything about League of Legends,
you know that the objective of the game
at its core is to take down
towers and destroy the enemy
teams nexus. Well, despite
this literally being the objective
of the game, Veivictus
Gaming would go on to destroy their
first ever tower
in their eleventh professional
match. To put
their performance record further into
perspective, I want to ask you
if you follow any traditional sporting
teams on social media.
Because basically every team's Twitter
or Instagram will make some sort of neat
graphic at the end of each match
announcing whether they won or lost.
Often times showcasing the best player
of the night on a win, and then on
the flip side leaving a we'll get em next
time sort of feel on a post
announcing a loss. And as
of recently, esports teams have taken
to this trend as well. And they
think Veivictus Gaming were no stranger.
They ended up posting a total of
eleven back-to-back graphics,
all of which were announcing
that they lost. It took
eleven games in a row
for whoever was running their Instagram
account to decide that
uh, okay.
This probably isn't going to happen, is it?
And it really didn't.
The team ended their competitive
career on a historic
28 match.
Ich frag mich grade,
also sonderlich
toll angefühlt
haben kann sich das jetzt nicht, ja.
Du quasi, du bist,
du setzt dich da hin und weißt von Anfang an,
du kriegst jetzt auf den Sack.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie dadurch
reich geworden sind.
34. It took Riot Games
in Russia 34
games to officially remove
Veivictus Gaming from competing
in the LCL.
Now, you might think that this was a complete
disaster for the Veivictus
organization. Ne, ne.
Ich glaube, das war das beste
für die, was passieren konnte. Ich meine,
die wollten aussteigen, die wollten ihre Sache
verkaufen. Keiner wollte sie kaufen.
Und sie waren jetzt, sie haben so viel
Aufmerksamkeit dadurch bekommen.
Ich glaube, das war das beste, was denen passieren konnte.
...the company's logistics, but some
would argue that it was actually a
success. Sure, these girls
embarrassed themselves at 34
different events, but if the company
at all believes in any
publicity being good publicity,
then they succeeded.
Because, believe it or not,
this team actually acquired fans.
Remember those Instagram posts
I talked about earlier? Well,
while looking through them, I found a lot
of encouraging comments coming from
Veivictus supporters.
Now, of course, some of these dudes were straight
simping, but others appeared to be
just fans who wanted to support them.
Kann mir einer erklären, was simping ist?
Das ist ja so das aktuelle...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Was ist simping?
Forzenknecht?
Was?
Okay.
Also sprich...
Also okay, dann versuch ich das mal
mit meinen Worten zu umschreiben.
Und ihr sagt mir, ob ich recht hab.
Also, es gibt eine Gruppe, die
quasi
ohne ersichtlichen
Grund und auch ohne, dass es irgendwie
stimmen würde, bei Mädels
schleimt den ganzen Tag.
Also, beispielsweise
das LOL-Team ist schlecht
und irgendjemand, der
halt übelst
rumschleimt, obwohl es
nichts zu schleimen gibt.
Okay, ja...
Wenn du von einem Girl das OBS
einrichtest und dir mehr erhoffst. Ah,
verstehe.
Ah, aha.
Ja, wie?
Ist OBS einrichten jetzt nicht der neueste
Shit?
Also...
Also, ich dachte immer, das macht dich ultra
attraktiv für Grills,
wenn du OBS einrichten kannst.
Ist das etwa nicht so?
Ich hätte schon gedacht, ich könnte ein bisschen punkten,
dadurch, dass ich OBS... Ich kann sogar Streamlabs
OBS einrichten, nicht nur OBS.
Streamlabs OBS,
OBS, ähm...
und Donation.
Donation-Accounts kann ich auch einrichten.
Optional kannst
du auch jeden Monat die Monatsmiete
im Stream donaten.
Doch, doch,
klar habe ich das schon gehört, aber ich konnte mir da nichts
darunter vorstellen.
Ich habe doch gerade selbst gesagt, das hörst du an jeder Ecke.
Aber ich habe mich noch nie großartig
gef... Mir war auch klar, dass es irgendwas
in Richtung bei Mädels rumschleimen
sein muss, aber ich habe mir da nie so
Gedanken drüber gemacht. Also, gut, im Prinzip
ist es einfach ein Schleimer, könnte man sagen.
Und trotz all' diesem Schleim, denke ich
eigentlich immer noch, dass der Tag, an dem
ein Mädels-Pro zur League of Legends kommt,
eigentlich bald kommt.
Aber es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht in Form eines gesamten Teams
von Mädels-Spielern
kommen, weil das ein Gimmick ist.
Anstattdessen wird es einen Tag geben,
wenn ein Mädels-Spieler auf dem
aktuellen professionellen Spiel-Level ist.
Das ist
dort wie bei allen anderen
E-Sports, Sports, sonst was, gerade
E-Sports-Sachen auch.
Wenn sich mal ein paar Mädels finden,
die auch den
Grind starten und das Spiel
quasi, jetzt nicht unbedingt LOL,
irgendwelche anderen Games, sagen wir mal, es kommt ein neues
Competitive, gut spielbares Competitive-Game
raus, ja, und du hast ein paar Mädels,
die sich da hinsetzen und
das Spiel 24-7
für ein halbes Jahr grinden, dann
werden die auch ganz gut sein.
Und wenn man mal in Richtung Overwatch
guckt, genau, das wollte ich nämlich
Ferxy, wollte ich gerade sagen,
gerade im Overwatch-Bereich gibt's
ja ein paar Mädels.
Ähm...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob's
wie hieß die, Griguri,
Giguri oder so noch gibt,
wobei ich da halt auch den Eindruck hatte,
also wenn man sich den Stream von ihr angeguckt hat,
das war ja früher ZaryaMain,
die ist echt gut, die spielt wirklich gut.
Wobei ich da den Eindruck hatte,
dass die in dem China-Team drinne war
und drinne bleiben durfte,
war halt auch so ein bisschen
...
ein bisschen Werbegag, letztendlich.
Aber die spielt echt gut,
muss man sagen.
Es gibt...
Es gibt
ein paar Mädels bei Star...
also ein Mädel bei StarCraft,
aber ich will jetzt da nicht
die Diskussionen drüber anstoßen.
Offiziell
ist sie eine Frau,
ja, und sie ist richtig gut.
Und ansonsten fallen mir nicht viele Mädels ein.
Im Schachbereich
gibt es, glaube ich, einige, die richtig gut sind,
aber Schach würde ich jetzt immer nicht so als
klassischen E-Sport zählen.
Ansonsten
fällt mir da jetzt nicht viel
ein,
wo es wirklich, sagen wir mal,
Tier-1-Teams gibt
mit Mädels.
Keine Ahnung.
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein.
Und das ist nicht so verrückt
als eine Idee.
Ein bisschen zuvor...
Ein bisschen zuvor
hat ein Team in Brasilien, das in der
Brasilien-Equivalente des LCS teilnimmt,
tatsächlich ihren ersten jährigen
Frauen-Spieler eingeladen. Sein Name war
Amy, und sie war ein Challenger-Support-Main.
Ich könnte längst über diese Situation reden,
aber für den meisten Teil war es
ein kurzer Blick, was passieren könnte,
wenn die Integration von Frauen
richtig gemacht wird.
Und wie gesagt, glaube ich...
Und die war wahrscheinlich...
Ich kenne das Team nicht, aber die war wahrscheinlich einfach gut.
Und die hat das Game wahrscheinlich auch 24-7 für
Monate, wenn nicht Jahre gegrindet.
...dass dieses Szenario sehr bald kommt.
Kommt zurück zu diesem Video,
wenn es passiert.
Aber bis dahin, verfolgt die Internet-Sicherheit,
mit ExpressVPN.
Das kam jetzt
unberechnet,
also unvorbereitet.
Lull.
Sag mal hier, warum du kein
Snickers kaufen solltest.
Okay Leute, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Slowmo, Virus,
Snickers,
das neue...
Das kenne ich schon, das ist nicht so gut.
Ähm...
COD-Campaign?
Snow?
Registry Keys? Irgendwelche Fachinformatiker-Dinger?
Okay, wir gucken Virus.
Virus.
The Actman is Trash.
Ist das so? Der hat ein paar ganz gute Videos.
Do old viruses work
on modern PCs?
There is your definitive answer.
DOS-Viruses
can indeed
give you a bad day.
Ah, yes.
Recently I bought
a new PC. It's a PC
with one purpose.
Testing. Whether that's
testing operating systems,
different hardware accessories,
different hard drives,
or even transferring 10,000
DOS-Viruses onto it, just to see
what happens. But why?
Yep, this little baby is going to go
through the wars, which is fine.
At 370
pounds, including the monitor,
keyboard, and this rather
sensual vertical mouse,
it's money well spent.
I'm actually pretty astonished for
what you can get
for that much money.
I mean, this has got a
Ryzen 5 3400G
with Vega 11
graphics, 8 GB of RAM,
a Maxster 240 GB
SSD, 2 GB
8 GB RAM, a Maxster
240 GB SSD, and this rather
fetching case, including
flappy drive opening.
All in all, it's a suitable
operating system and we're good to go.
10 pounds for a copy of Windows
10 Pro. That'll do.
Ah, well,
I'm not sure if I can
get a copy of Windows 10 Pro
or not.
I'm not sure if I can get
a copy of Windows 10 Pro.
That'll do.
Ah, Windows.
Things are so easy
these days. No conflicting
hardware, no device drivers
to install, no corrupt
floppy disks. It all does it
itself. In its own way, it's kind of
nice, although I miss...
Das einzige, was mir echt
jedes Mal auf den Keks geht,
bei einem Windows Setup, ist das
wegklicken von den Datenschutz
Dingern am Anfang.
Wollen Sie anonyme Statistiken? Nein.
Wollen Sie Location Tracking? Nein.
Die Cookies? Nein. Wollen Sie das? Nein.
Wollen Sie das? Nein. Ey, jedes Mal
und das sind irgendwie 15 Fragen oder so.
Ne, Cortana ist
nicht mal am Start.
Cortana haben sie abgeschafft beim Start.
Cortana war nervig, ja.
Ja.
Na ja, irgendwelche
DOS-Batch-Dinger
gehen immer noch.
Wie?
Wie geht denn das,
dass man auf so modernen PC nicht
Duke Nukem 3D laufen lassen kann?
Warum sammelt man sowas?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Warum nicht?
Ja, ist glaube ich eher die Frage.
Und das ist wirklich ein großer Teil dessen, was die DOS-Malware-Szene betrifft.
Programmierer, die ihre Muskeln flexieren, ihre Fähigkeiten zeigen und manchmal den Bootsektor verlassen.
Oder mindestens fünf Jahre Geschäftsangehörigkeit. Im Prozess. Es ist alles ein Teil des Kurses.
Es ist alles ein Teil des Kurses.
Man findet oft, dass viele DOS-Malware von demselben Lohnprogrammer oder Coding-Gruppe sind, mit Pseudonymen, die über den Ort flashen.
Ich meine, was ist der Grund dafür, 100 Stunden Coding in etwas zu werfen, wenn man das Akkord nicht bekommt?
Oder auf jeden Fall eine echte Verschuldung dafür.
Jetzt, Windows 10 ist tatsächlich ein Descendant von Windows NT.
Und um DOS-Programme zu erzeugen, muss man etwas nennen, was NT-VDM oder NT-Virtual-DOS-Maschine nennt.
Moment, das gibt es heute noch?
Es ist um jeden 16-Bit-DOS-Code, den man versucht zu erzeugen, und es tut sein Bestes.
Natürlich ist es nicht sehr beliebt. Microsoft verursacht keine aktiven Entwicklungszeiten darin.
Aber es wird verschiedene DOS-Programme mit dem seltenen Stück Malware verwendet.
Normalerweise die, ohne Grafik oder Geräusche.
Also wissen wir, dass dieses alte, desinfizierte Malware auf Windows 10 erzeugt werden kann.
Aber um herauszufinden, ob es Schaden erzeugen kann, brauchen wir das echte, volle Malware in seiner ganzen Glorie.
Das ist, wo die VX-Heaven-Virus-Kollektion ins Spiel kommt.
Das ist...
Okay, es scheint wirklich einige Archive zu geben davon.
VX-Heaven, also Virus-Exchange-Heaven, war, und manchmal immer noch ist, eine Seite, die Informationen über Computerviruse bietet.
Es ist keine militärische Instanz, aber das scheint es nicht zu verhindern, dass sie von den ukrainischen Behörden geradet wird und regelmäßig geschlossen wird.
Aber sie haben auch ein großes Archiv von alten DOS- und Windows-Maschinen.
Diese sind wirklich genannt als Zoo-Virus, da sie nicht in aktiver Zirkulation sind.
Aber Prokrastin...
Wenn man einen Virus-Scan durchführt, erkennt man die größte Mehrheit von ihnen.
Das ist also beinahe bemerkenswert und etwas unnervierlich.
Der nächste Schritt ist, einige zu laden und zu sehen, was passiert.
Die nächste Schritt ist, einige zu laden und zu sehen, was passiert.
NotreWEALT
und nicht bemerkt, dass sie mit Malware infiziert worden ist.
Malware könnte dann ihre Sache machen,
Memory Resident werden,
den Bootsektor infizieren,
oder einfach andere File unbekannt zu dir infizieren.
Von diesem Punkt an könnte man...
andere Personen infizieren,
oder vielleicht einen Floppy Disk mit einem infizierten Bootsektor an einen anderen,
und deren System würde dann infiziert werden.
Die meisten Malware werden dich nicht direkt bedrohen,
da sie einen Zeitraum der Ruhe benötigen,
um sich ein bisschen zu kopieren,
wie bei einem echten Virus.
Wenn die Situation richtig geworden ist,
dass ihr Geld erholt,
könnt ihr in eine Welt von Schmerzen sein.
Ob du ein lustiges Display bekommst,
hängt sehr viel von der Malware ab.
Aber...
Cool, cool.
Was?
Krasser Hacker-Man.
Das ist ja ein ziemlich low-protein Virus.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den SL-Zug unter Linux.
.
Erinnert mich schon.
Erinnert mich nicht.
Das ist kein
.
Das ist eine
Ein
.
Ja, wow.
abhängig von den anderen executables, bis ich sie stoppte.
Also direkt von Anfang an haben wir unsere Antwort.
Ja, DOS-Malware kann auf deinem modernen PC immer noch funktionieren, besonders wenn es
eine 32-Bit-Version von Windows 10 runnt.
Vielleicht nicht komplett richtig in diesem Fall, aber es versucht immer noch etwas
Unvergütbares zu machen.
Wenn ich die anderen jetzt bloaten .com-File runnen würde, wären sie einfach zu groß
zu öffnen, also hat es die anderen kaputt gemacht.
Also hat es dieses Virus tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr furchtbarer gemacht, als es
früher war.
Hier ist ein weiterer, der Casino genannt wird.
Nun, auf Payload Delivery würde der Code die File-Allocation-Tabelle auf deinem Drive
aufwenden, aber nicht bevor du es in die Erinnerung kopierst.
Der Benutzer wird dann zu einem Spiel von Karten gefordert, drei Pound-Symbolen ausdrucken,
die 17,2% Chancen haben, und das FAT wird zurückgeschrieben.
Du gehst zurück zum Disk und du bist sicher, bekommst nichts anderes und dein System hängt,
leaving you needing to reboot, to a machine, which of course will no longer boot.
Now fortunately, updates to the Windows file system and boot sectors mean that malware
like this won't be successful, even if it does execute successfully.
Ich mein, man hätte einfach, anstatt das Minispiel zu spielen, hätte man einfach den
Rechner neu starten können.
.com-File runnt.
Aber es gibt keine File-Allocation-Table für den Delete.
Casinos Method of Duplication was, to infect the command.com-File in your Drivers root
directory, which was an essential part of DOS.
But because Windows no longer has that file, running the malware now just displays this
message.
Copyright SNS International 1990.
If I was to change the system date to either the 15th of January, April or August, which
is when the payload delivers.
When the code does actually try to delete our FAT, but it fails and Windows tells us
about it with an error.
We also do actually get the game of cards, but the NTVDM doesn't appreciate some of
the calls it's making to memory, and so can't acquiesce to that either.
Oh well, I mean, it feels a bit wrong, but I'm actually willing viruses to work at
this point.
Easykiller schreibt, obwohl gab's auch letztes Mal einen Bericht, dass einer von den Erpresserviren,
die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich
von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den
Erpresserviren befindet.
Die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die
sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich
von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich von den Erpresserviren befindet, die sich selbst
entschlüsselt hat wegen Corona.
Das ist nicht das erste Mal.
Es gab ein paar Verschlüsselungstrojaner oder sonst was, wo die Hersteller nach einer
Weile den Key rausgerückt haben.
Es gab doch auch mal den Bericht, wo irgendjemand geschrieben hat, so nach dem Motto, er muss
jetzt verhungern und kann seine Kinder nicht mehr versorgen, wo die dann geantwortet haben,
ja, hier ist der Key.
Okay, how about the hate virus?
Well, here's a virus...
Hate speech!
The autofocus einer Kamera macht mich verrückt!
Oh.
Bill...
Bingo.
Oh.
Oh...
bio
Ok, der löscht nur den Speicher, der überschreibt nicht das Bio selbst, weil das wäre echt fail
Express-VPN
Der Lautstärkeunterschied dürfte doch gar nicht so groß sein, oder?
Oder? Ein bisschen
Max, streamst du den ganzen Nachmittag durch? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht
Ich finde irgendwie, das war voll kreativ noch, das ganze Virus-Zeug
Zwar nicht, wir verschlüsseln da eine Festplatte und
überweist Bitcoins
Die haben sich ja noch richtig Mühe gegeben
Es sieht aus, als ob es in DOS-Box enthalten ist
Denkt daran, das sind die echten File auf eurem echten Hard-Drive
Wenn ihr euch die Montage-Folge auf Windows anschaut, werdet ihr eine Menge von jetzt infekterten Filen sehen
Also müsst ihr vorsichtig sein, auch wenn ihr mit Emulatoren oder virtuellen Maschinen arbeitet
Ihr setzt potenziell...
Also ich würde es auf jeden Fall
niemals auf meinem Host ausführen
Auch nicht mit DOS-Box
Sondern immer in der VM
No happy meal for you, 12 Monate Poggers
Exzellent Subscription!
...eine Umgebung, die eure Daten zerstören könnte
Auch eine Entschuldigung für das furchtbare LCD-Filmen hier
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt, bis ich...
Capture Card in 2020, lul
...in dem Editing-Programm bekommen habe
Aber das ist nass
LGR würde nicht glücklich sein
Ein letzter Party-Trick
Wie ist es, wenn wir all diese Mangelware nehmen
und sie alle runtern
Mal sehen, ob wir diesen Computer wirklich verletzen können
Das ist das DOS-Ren
Hier sind unsere Virus-File
Zuerst werde ich...
...die Flexibilität des REN-Kommandes nutzen, um alle diese Mangelware in funktionierbare COM-File zu renamen
Wegen der genannten Namenkonventionen
wird es auch alle Duplikate ausweiten
und wir sind jetzt mit 6.745 Mangelwaren übrig
Exzellent!
Jetzt werde ich eine Mangelware...
Das sagt das! Habt ihr das gehört?
Es wird auch alle Duplikate ausweiten
und wir sind jetzt mit 6.745 Mangelwaren übrig
Exzellent!
Jetzt werde ich eine Mangelware in PowerShell herstellen
die durch diese File runtern wird
und sie verletzen
Wir müssen schauen, ob unsere Virus-File da sind
Okay, der führt jetzt wirklich alle 16.000 aus
Run...
Dies sollte für alle nach dem anderen runtern
Also, ich werde 7.000 Virus auf diesem Computer veröffentlichen
Wünsche mir Glück!
Okay, PowerShell kämpft bereits damit
Ich werde also manuell ein paar Virus öffnen
nur um das Mayhem hinzuzufügen
Wow!
User Peter!
Na, irgendeiner wird doch funktionieren!
Come on, bruh!
Es gibt definitiv Virus-Aktivitäten
Irgendein Virus-Aktivität!
Irgendetwas geht los und es...
Es verletzt alle diese anderen File
Nach nicht zu langer Zeit war es klar,
dass es ernsthafte Probleme gab
Alle COM-File haben sich über mehrere Male
auf ihre originale Größe gesteigert
vermutlich, sobald sie weiter verletzt werden
durch das already running Mangelware
Dies verursachte auch Probleme für Windows PowerShell
und es begann Probleme zu öffnen
überhaupt nichts
Nicht zu erwähnen war jetzt ein .com-File
namens 100.com in der Direktorie
Aber es gab viel Schlimmeres außerhalb dessen
Oh Mann, was...
Schau dir das an!
Ich kann nicht mal...
Ja?
...meine Maus umdrehen
Ich mache hier etwas seltsames
Ich meine, das ist nicht gut
Ich meine, was ist...
Was ist hier los?
Schau dir das an!
Es ist absolut verletzt!
Also, das ist...
Das ist dein definitiver Antwort
Das Virus kann dir tatsächlich...
...einen schlechten Tag geben
Was ist das?
remand.com
Nicht ausführen!
Wer weiß, was da rauskommt!
Es ist ein File namens remand.com
auf der Desktop
Es gibt auch command.com
Ich meine, kann ich mal versuchen Total-AV zu starten?
Wird es sogar öffnen?
Lass uns die Sicherung einstellen und sehen, was passiert
Ich denke, dieser Computer könnte offiziell verletzt werden
Zehntausend Währungen von Excellent!
...verletzt werden
Das ist nicht bedeutend, ich habe einen sehr heiligen...
Oh! Oh! Oh!
...Hard Drive
Ich kann nicht mal...
...eine Highlight Box machen
Es bleibt einfach im Hintergrund
Das ist wirklich verletzt!
Oh Mann!
Okay, also der Aufschuss davon ist, dass...
...ja, DOS-Era-Malware kann tatsächlich...
...Karnage verursachen...
Ja, hätte mich auch gewundert, wenn nicht!
...bis jetzt
Also ist es am besten, es zu vermeiden
Ernsthaft, bitte, mach das nicht!
Okay, an diesem Punkt möchte ich Total-AV Antivirus bedanken
Ich brauche...
Okay, jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen Sellout
Ich muss mir jetzt ein bisschen legen, weil...
...ich muss mir jetzt ein bisschen Lego angucken
Excellent!
Lego Schnee...
Was ist das?
Was ist denn ein Snow...
...Plow...
...Train?
Schnee...
...Gebläse?
Was auch immer
Schneeräumen!
Schnee-Flug!
Ah!
Äh...
Ich glaube, da ist so der Lego-Motor nicht das Richtige für...
...die Musik!
Was ist das?
Oioioioi!
BTF, was ist das für Musik?
BTF, was ist das für Rap-Musik, Alter?
Oioioioi!
Oioi!
Three Head!
Oh, jetzt kommt hier der Big Brain Move!
Warum dampft das da oben?
Uah!
Moment, es kann hupen!
Die Musik, die macht mich fertig!
Es funktioniert!
So, und damit jetzt...
...damit darf er jetzt den ganzen Hof sauber machen!
Oioioi, Step!
Dein lieber Eier-Ja-Step!
Ey...
Was auch immer...
Ist das aus dem PC?
Was?
Äh...
Windows abgekackt!
Das ist langweilig!
Das ist bestimmt auch langweilig!
Okay, wir gucken uns Slow-Motion an!
Slow-Motion von was?
Von...
Termite!
Was ist denn Termite?
Auf...
Auf Deutsch...
Termit!
Okay...
Das ist tatsächlich mal eine Übersetzung, wo man drauf kommen kann, dass...
...die Musik...
was nur 1000 da geht aber mehr ich habe schon 240 das gibt es in battlefield 4 auch das ist
dieses ding was man werfen kann diese diese dieser granatenersatz in battlefield 4 und
in in dings in warzone gibt es auch außerdem wie soll ich wollte sagen wie sollen wir 1000
fps sehen überhaupt nachdem das menschliche auge nur zwölf kann ripptopf jay cone 12 aber
du hast zum glück zwei augen also kommst du auf 24
das ist das aus wenn du drei augen hast dann siehst du das geht bloß bis 2 da ist
cap bei 24 fps ist cap egal wie viele augen und hat irgendwie schon ein bisschen hypnotische
wirkung da sieht aus wie ein vulkan ausbruch das schwäbische waffenregen genau
ist der f-16 nicht ein flugzeug
also entweder den sich das jetzt so weit aus dass das glas ding
vielleicht so weit aus dass das glas ding vielleicht so weit aus dass das glas ding
platzt glaube ich aber nicht wahrscheinlich wirst du einfach blasen
sehen ja ich wirst einfach blasen sehen
blub blub blub blub
das ist ein bisschen anders als wenn du nur maltenmetall in das wasser spüren würdest
wenn du das noch nie gesehen hast wirst du das als das maltenliquid runterfällt
matze 29 drei monate dankeschön exzellent
morgen
die 2
Ah, yes.
Casey86, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Oh, der Scam-Train ist unterwegs, Leute.
Der Scam-Train läuft.
Wie viele Abos haben die eigentlich?
Boah, 14 Millionen.
Fuck, Alter.
Ich wusste, dass die groß sind, aber nicht, dass die so groß sind.
Weil die machen ja seit Jahren im Prinzip genau das.
Slow motion von irgendwelchen Dingern.
Hättest du auch, wenn du regelmäßig Videos machst,
dann müsste ich aber äußerst regelmäßig Videos machen
und anderen Content vor allem.
Zeug kaputt machen.
Zeug kaputt machen in Slow-Mo.
Ja.
Kusswort, dankeschön.
Oh, BitConnect.
Dankeschön, zwei Monate.
So.
Und was ist jetzt der Unterschied zu vorher?
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Wieso haben wir manche E-Mounts doppelt?
Haben wir die? Welche haben wir denn doppelt?
Die verrückte Anzahl der E-Mounts, die durch die Wärme der Molten-Thermosphäre produziert werden.
Ey, es sieht schon irgendwie cool aus, ja.
Zwar komplett sinnlos, aber es ist cool.
Okay, Odi, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Subscription, huge.
Die Wasser selbst quencht die Reaktion nicht,
also musst du sie einfach auswärmen.
Und am Ende bist du nur mit sehr brittischen Stößen von Eier übrig.
Okay, Champ.
Haben wir nicht, haben wir nicht, okay, Champ, schon aktiviert?
Ani, weird Champ haben wir.
Ich glaub, okay Champ haben wir nicht.
Wir haben kein okay Champ, das füg ich gleich mal hinzu.
Okay Champ.
Moment, gleich haben wir okay Champ.
So, okay Champ ist geadded.
Aber das dauert kurz.
Jep, jep füg ich nicht hinzu.
Jep darf nur ich benutzen hier.
Nee, Pog, Pog, Pog-O ist richtig dumm.
Warum wollt ihr Pog-O verwenden?
Okay, Chat, jetzt habe ich mal eine Frage.
An welcher Stelle verwendet man Pog-O?
Wann ist, welche Situation muss sein, dass man Pog-O verwendet?
Wenn ihr mir das, dann füge ich es hinzu.
Das ist das neue Jep.
Pog-O ist weird Champ Ersatz.
Okay.
Okay, Pog-O.
E-Mode.
Okay, ich hab's hinzugefügt.
Ich hab's hinzugefügt.
Aber wie gesagt, dauert immer kurz und außerdem muss man Chat refreshen.
Dass es funktioniert.
Wie oft will er das jetzt noch machen?
Oh, der ganze Eimer fackelt hier ab.
Warum können nicht Emojis durch Twitch-Emojis ersetzt werden?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Es ist ehrlich gesagt viel los hier.
Ihr seht, dass die Thermal Reaktion begonnen ist.
Aber eine Menge Puder ist unter dem Wasser gefallen und jetzt explodiert wieder aus.
Okay, ich erkenne jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel.
Außer, dass es ein bisschen aussieht wie an Silvester.
Interessant ist, wenn ich es zurückdrehe.
Seht ihr, wie schnell die Seite dieses Körpers malter wird.
Also hat die Reaktion gerade angefangen.
Sobald all diese Puder auf dem Weg gelaufen sind.
Nur so weit, wo es in der Lage ist.
Es ist bereits gläubig.
Also in der realen Zeit, das ist etwa ein Drittel von einem Sekunden,
dass dieses Körbchen quasi flüssig geworden ist.
Es hat einfach nur zugeben und eingefallen.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Äh.
Okay, das machen die halt schon eine Weile und das kommt gut an.
Die haben bestimmt bessere Videos in der Richtung.
Das fand ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend.
Warum du kein Snickers kaufen solltest.
Warum denn?
Warum soll man kein Snickers kaufen?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt erklären lassen.
Bestimmt weil Kinderarbeit oder so.
Echt?
Flame Haze.
Null.
Irgendwie dachte ich es mir schon.
Werbung noch?
Kennt ihr diese Werbung noch?
Besser?
Du bist nicht du, wenn du hungrig bist.
Snickers und der Hunger ist gegessen.
Seit 90 Jahren versorgt das amerikanische Unternehmen Mars Incorporated die Welt mit Snickers.
Und von Beginn an waren vermutlich Kinder an der Herstellung beteiligt.
Nicht als Testesser, sondern als Arbeitssklaven auf einer der unzähligen Kakaoplantagen in Westafrika.
Anfang der 2000er gab es das erste Mal solche Vorwürfe.
Eine Investigativdokumentation der BBC
Da ist aber Snickers nicht das einzige.
Das macht's nicht besser.
Die machte damals die ganze Welt auf das riesige Problem aufmerksam.
Die Journalisten interviewten malawische Kindersklaven.
Diese waren an Kakaoplantagen in der Elfenbeinküste verkauft worden.
There's nothing to stop these young men leaving the plantation.
Except that they've been trafficked 300 miles from home.
They're penniless and they have no idea where they are.
Paid nothing, unable to leave and totally controlled by the farmer.
Neben Mars standen auch Schokoladenproduzenten wie Hershey und Nestle in der Kritik.
Sie alle räumten ein, dass in der Vergangenheit einiges schief gelaufen sei.
Jetzt wolle man die Kinderarbeit auf Kakaoplantagen aber bekämpfen.
Mittlerweile sind fast 20...
Kannst du das Video machen, warum man kein Apple-Sum so gern macht?
Warum man kein Apple-Sum kaufen sollte?
Ja, mal gucken. Können wir uns auch angucken.
Und naja, es hat sich so gut wie nichts getan.
Warum auch? Die Leute kaufen den Kram. Und solange die Leute den Kram kaufen, warum sollten sie was ändern?
Ich mein, das ist ja die beste Situation für so einen Hersteller, rein aus Money-Sicht.
Quasi, die Sache ist an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen.
Es ist bekannt. Es interessiert keine Sau.
Also, Money, Money. Stomps.
Die Kinder der Schokoladenindustrie haben das massive Problem immer noch nicht in den Griff bekommen.
Die wollen gar nicht.
Millionen von Kindern schuften auch im Jahr 2020.
Die wollen nicht.
Tag für Tag unter Unmenschlichkeit.
Wie gesagt, das Beste, was denen passieren kann, ist, die Leute wissen es, den Leuten ist es egal, sie kaufen den Scheiß weiterhin.
Weil das Einzige, was dazu führen könnte, dass sie das anders machen, ist, dass die Leute es nicht mehr kaufen.
Oder aber da kommen halt irgendwelche Leute mit, also nicht Stomps-Leute, sondern Leute mit irgendwie noch ein bisschen Einfühlvermögen ran.
Aber das ist ja da nicht gewollt.
Amtwot ist neu hier!
Ach nee, es heißt am2d wahrscheinlich.
Quatsch.
...bedingungen auf den Plantagen.
Sie müssen Kakao-Früchte mit Macheten vom Baum schlagen und Bohnen in gewöhnter Hitze zum Trocknen auf Bananenblättern auslegen.
Sie müssen schwere Säcke schleppen und ungeschützt giftige Pestizide versprühen.
Keines der großen Schokoladenunternehmen kann garantieren, dass ihre Schokolade frei von Kinderarbeit ist.
Schokoladenunternehmen kann garantieren, dass ihre Schokolade frei von Kinderarbeit ist. Viele
wissen teils nicht einmal, von welchen Farmen ihre Kakaobohnen... Hast du dir im Stream auch
mal Tempel OS angeschaut? Nee. Wie kann das sein? Wie kann man so versagen? Äh, es interessiert
einfach keinen. Aus ihrer Sicht haben die wahrscheinlich nicht versagt. Aus ihrer Sicht
denken sie, okay, solange die Leute den Scheiß kaufen, warum sollen wir es ändern? Als würde
die das irgendwie... Als würde die das auch nur ansatzweise interessieren, dass dort Kinder
auf der Kakaoplantage arbeiten. Das ist denen doch vollkommen egal. Das ist genauso, wie
die Leute bei Kik nicht juckt, dass das irgendein, keine Ahnung, Bangladesch irgendwelche Kinder
genäht haben oder irgendwelche Elektronikteile unter unmenschlichen Bedingungen in China
und Nordkorea produziert werden. Sonst juckt die Leute einfach nicht. Und solange es die
Leute nicht juckt und sie den Kram nicht kaufen, wird es auch die Hersteller wenig jucken.
Weil da hat doch keiner irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewissen, was das angeht.
Für Schokolade braucht man Kakaobohnen. Die stammen größtenteils aus Westafrika, insbesondere
aus der Elfenbeinküste und Ghana. Dort arbeiten Kinder, weil sie billige Arbeitskräfte sind
und die Bauern sich keine Erwachsenen leisten können. Bei einigen Kinderarbeitern haben
Menschenhändler ihre Finger im Spiel. Das benachbarte Burkina Faso ist noch ärmer als
Ghana und die Elfenbeinküste. Kinder vertrauen sich dort oft skrupellosen
Schleppern an, in der Hoffnung auf ein besseres Leben. Dann werden sie aber versklavt und
an ivorische Kakaoplantagen verkauft. Die allermeisten Kinder sind jedoch in Familienbetrieben
tätig. Schulen sind oft zu teuer oder es gibt keine. Ihre einzige Perspektive ist die
Arbeit auf der Familienplantage. Es wird immer mehr Kakao angebaut und nachgefragt. Dementsprechend
ist die Anzahl der Kinderarbeiter ebenfalls gestiegen.
Zwischen 2009 und 2014 sind über 440.000 Kinder dazu gekommen. Insgesamt sind mittlerweile
über 2 Millionen Kinder auf ivorischen und ghanaischen Plantagen tätig.
Das gigantische Problem betrifft die Kinder, die sich für die Kinder in den Alltag verletzen.
Die werden sich wahrscheinlich denken, so doof es klingt, gibt's genug Kindernachschub.
Und solange es sich nicht finanziell bei denen auswirkt, wird da wahrscheinlich niemals jemand
was dran ändern. Es sei denn, die Bedingungen drum herum ändern sich.
Die Kinder werden nicht mehr in den Alltag verletzt, während sie nicht mehr in den Alltag verletzt werden.
Die Kinder werden nicht mehr in der Alltag verletzt, während sie nicht mehr in der Alltag verletzt werden.
und ist nur sehr schwer zu lösen.
Das wissen die Konzerne natürlich auch.
Es gibt nicht die eine oder die zwei gigantischen Plantagen,
die man einfach dichtmachen könnte.
Tatsächlich sind es knapp zwei Millionen äußerst kleine Betriebe.
Der Weg des Kakaos von dort in die Maßfabriken in Europa und den USA
ist lang und undurchsichtig.
Also, wortwörtlich.
Oft gibt es keine Straßen,
und man kann die Plantagen nur über lange Fußwege erreichen.
Der Kampf gegen Kinderarbeit ...
Mich würde sogar mal interessieren,
ob, mal angenommen, dort gibt es irgendwie eine Plantage,
die Eltern sind am Start und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zehn Kinder,
kommt ja öfters mal vor, dass man dann mehr Kinder hat,
was die Leute dazu sagen.
Wenn das die einzige Möglichkeit ist, da irgendwie Geld zu verdienen,
wohl gemerkt halt, natürlich werden sie ausgebeutet.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was die Leute selbst dazu sagen.
Also, sprich, wenn du dort Kinder aus so einer Plantage fragen würdest,
ob sie da quasi so eine Art Arbeitssklaven sind,
was sie dazu sagen würden.
Weil vielleicht sagen da auch einige dazu,
das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, Geld zu verdienen,
wie wir hier über die Runden kommen.
Natürlich macht es das nicht besser.
Vor allem, wenn du dir überlegst, dass die wahrscheinlich 0,01 %
von dem gesamten Produkt abbekommen im Endeffekt an Kohle.
Ist gleichzeitig ein Kampf gegen Armut.
Die langfristige Lösung für das Problem klingt relativ simpel.
Die Bauern müssen fair vergütet werden.
Ja.
Okay, okay, das ist natürlich ein Schenkelklopfer.
Aber dann könnten viele ihre Kinder zur Schule schicken
und sich erwachsene Arbeiter leisten.
Doch trotz Zertifikaten, trotz massiver Berichterstattung
und trotz Verboten verdienen sie immer noch zu wenig.
Und das ...
Weißt du, es juckt halt letztendlich keinen.
Und dementsprechend stellt da auch keiner sein Kaufverhalten um.
Weltweit von Jahr zu Jahr immer mehr Leute Schokolade essen.
Sie haben keine Lobby und bei Preisverhandlungen
so gut wie keine Macht.
Wenn sie mehr Geld verlangen, findet man Millionen andere Bauern,
die den niedrigen Preis akzeptieren.
Jedes Land der Welt hat die UN-Kinderrechtskonvention
von 1989 unterschrieben.
Also, bis auf die USA.
Kinder sollen ...
Hell yeah!
... zur Ausbeutung geschützt werden und haben ein Recht auf Bildung.
Eigentlich sind natürlich jeweils die Regierungen der einzelnen Länder
für die Einhaltung dieser Kinderrechte verantwortlich.
Die Elfenbeinküste ist aber zum Beispiel kaum in der Lage ...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das ist ja auch das Papier nicht wert, auf dem's steht.
... kümmern.
Das Land ist arm, korrupt
und in den vergangenen 20 Jahren gab es zwei Bürgerkriege.
Okay, kurzes Quiz.
Wie viel Geld steht der Ivorischen Spezialeinheit
für die Bekämpfung von Menschenhandel und Kinderarbeit
jährlich zur Verfügung?
Naja, so viel haben die wahrscheinlich im ganzen Jahr nicht.
Dann müssen's wahrscheinlich 5.000 sein.
So viel Geld haben die nicht.
Woher sollen die so viel Geld haben?
Das können höchstens 5.000 sein.
Also, 5 Millionen wär schon echt, ja ...
5.000 Dollar.
Fünf.
Tausend.
Als Reaktion auf die massive Berichterstattung wurden 2001 strengere Gesetze
für die globalen Schokoladenproduzenten gefordert.
In den USA gab es bereits einen Gesetzesentwurf
für ein industrieweites Label.
Dagegen haben die Hersteller aber erfolgreich Lobbyarbeit betrieben.
Als Kompromiss wurde 2001 das ...
Moment.
Da gibt's die Ersten, die jetzt schon wieder drüber meckern würden,
weil das schwarze Hände sind.
Als Kompromiss ...
Wobei es in dem Fall halt echt passt.
... wurde 2001 das Harkin-Engel-Protocol unterzeichnet.
Es verpflichtete Maas, Nestle, Hershey und einige weitere Hersteller
gegen Kinderarbeit auf Kakao-Plantagen vorzugehen.
Die Umsetzung war aber genau wie die Unterzeichnung des Plans ...
Das ist so ein Ding, ja, wir untersch ...
Wisst ihr, da saßen jetzt irgendwie ...
Wie viele haben da unterschrieben, hier?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, sieben.
Da saßen jetzt irgendwie acht CEOs im Fünf-Sterne-Restaurant,
oder auf der Insel im Fünf-Sterne-Puff, keine Ahnung,
und haben sich gegenseitig die Hände geschüttelt und gesagt,
oh, ein zukunftsrechtliches Abkommen.
Und als sie da rausgegangen sind, haben sie sich gedacht, ja, who cares.
Nestle, Hershey und einige weitere Hersteller
gegen Kinderarbeit auf Kakao-Plantagen vorzugehen.
Das ist so ein Ding, das ist auch wieder das Papier nicht wert, worauf es steht.
Die Umsetzung war aber, genau wie die Unterzeichnung des Plans, freiwillig.
Und wer hätte es gedacht?
Bis heute wurden wichtige Teile des Plans nicht erfüllt.
Deadlines wurden immer wieder verfehlt oder um mehrere Jahre verschoben.
Auch wenn Maas, Nestle, Hershey und Co. gerne so tun, als ob in der Vergangenheit...
Das ist wie mit unseren Kohlekraftwerken. Da sind wir mal 2038 jetzt.
...haben sie keine Verantwortung übernommen.
Auch das neue Ziel für 2020 wird aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach wieder nichts.
Als Teil des Plans sollte 2005 auch ein industrieweites Sieg
eingeführt werden. Das hat bis heute noch nicht geklappt.
Stattdessen stellen nun...
Naja, freiwillig machen die das ja auch nicht.
Warum sollen die sich freiwillig auf ihre Packung was draufdrucken?
Das ist so, wie wenn sich die Zigarettenhersteller freiwillig diese Bildchen draufdrucken würden.
Warum sollen die freiwillig auf ihre Packung drucken?
Diese Schokolade wird in Kinderarbeit hergestellt.
... andere Organisationen Zertifikate für Kakao aus.
Sie garantieren zumindest, dass Bauern...
besser vergütet werden und investieren in Kampagnen gegen Kinderarbeit.
Mittlerweile gibt es wahnsinnig viele dieser Anbieter, die miteinander konkurrieren.
Sie bieten zertifizierte Kakaobohnen zu unterschiedlichen Preisen an.
Schokoladenproduzenten greifen immer häufiger zu den günstigsten Varianten.
Der Großteil der von Fairtrade zertifizierten Bauernfamilien in der Elfenbeinküste
lebte 2018 immer noch unter der absoluten Armutsgrenze.
Und das trotz garantiertem Mindestpreis...
und festgelegter Prämie.
Der führende Zertifikatsanbieter, die Rainforest Alliance, zahlt den Bauern zwar auch mehr Geld als üblich,
es gibt aber keinen Mindestpreis.
Bauern sind vor fallenden Kakaopreisen also gar nicht geschützt.
Na, wenn überall so ein Siegel drauf ist, aber gleichzeitig das Siegel nicht sicherstellen kann,
dass keine Kinder arbeiten, was bedeutet das denn letztendlich?
Zertifikate sind also keine 100%...
Ja, was das bedeutet, ist ganz einfach.
Die Hersteller können was draufdrucken und freuen sich.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Ihr wisst ja, ich arbeite im Finanzsektor, aber in der IT, ich habe damit ja nichts zu tun.
Dort ist es gang und gäbe, dass sich irgendwelche Siegel draufgepappt werden,
die im Zweifelsfall... im Zweifelsfall wurden die selbst ausgestellt, ist vollkommen egal.
Da klebt auch auf allem irgendein komisches Wichtig-to-Siegel drauf, so nach dem Motto
Sieger 2020 und bla und sonst wie.
Das ist das Papier auch nicht wert, wo draufsteht.
Garantie, dass Schokolade frei von Kinder...
Das klingt logisch.
Wir haben fünf der größten Schokoladenproduzenten kontaktiert.
Unsere Fragen bezüglich des Harkin-Engel-Protokolls wurden ignoriert.
Ein einheitliches Industrie-Siegel wird anscheinend auch nicht befürwortet.
Alle Unternehmen betonen, dass Systeme entwickelt wurden, durch die gefährdete Kinder auf Farmen identifiziert und besser geschützt werden.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Darüber hinaus wollen alle Produzenten in den nächsten fünf Jahren nur noch zertifizierte Kakaobohnen nutzen,
tun es schon oder wollen ihre eigenen Standards weiter ausbauen.
All diese Initiativen der Industrie wirken vielversprechend und proaktiv.
Aber reichen sie aus?
Diese Sachen sind einfach nur da, dass man auf unangenehme Rückfragen sagen kann, man macht da was.
Man will ja da gar nichts machen.
Reichen sie aus?
Das ist Brainwashing.
Das ist einfach sich selber ein gutes Gewissen machen.
Autor und Kinderrechtsaktivist Benjamin Witter beschäftigt sich seit über...
Das ist ein bisschen so, wie die ganzen Unternehmen, die seit Jahren quasi Umwelt verschmutzen oder für Verbrennungssachen werben,
jetzt auf einmal Bäume pflanzen und tolle Programme haben für Windkraft und wir waren schon immer wahnsinnig grün und sonst was.
Auch kompletter Blödsinn.
Das ist einfach nur, um sich hinzustellen und sagen zu können, oh wir sind ja ganz toll.
30 Jahre mit Kinderarbeit auf der ganzen Welt.
Wirklich hilft nicht Freiwilligkeit, wirklich hilft nicht Eigenkontrollen, wirklich hilft nur unabhängige Kontrollen von außen.
Pyta fordert deshalb seit Jahrzehnten ein Lieferkettengesetz.
Das könnte dazu beitragen, dass Menschenrechte in der gesamten Lieferkette und damit auch im Ausland geschützt werden müssen.
Ah.
Dass es dringend Regulierung braucht, sehen mittlerweile auch Menschenrechte.
... das ist dringend Regulierung braucht, sehen mittlerweile auch Menschenrechte.
auch einige der großen Schokoladenhersteller ein.
Wir als Konsumenten müssen jetzt aber nicht auf Schokolade ...
Also, ich hätte eine Idee, was man dagegen machen könnte.
So der Kokona-Way wäre,
wir könnten einfach Waffen an die Kinder auf den Plantagen exportieren.
Und wir wissen ja, sobald man Waffen hat, ist alles besser.
Was dann ... Ansonsten kann es rechts auch egal sein.
Und wir sind ja gut da drin, was Waffenexportieren angeht.
Und ich meine, wer braucht nicht eine eigene AK-74?
Oder, na gut, wir sind ja keine Russen.
Wer braucht nicht eine G36?
Eine eigene ...
Das ist doch logisch, oder?
... verzichten oder so.
Das würde Millionen von Bauern die Lebensgrundlage rauben.
Wir können Unternehmen mit unserer Kaufentscheidung aber dazu zwingen,
auf zertifizierte Kakaobohnen zu setzen.
Eventuell zahlen wir dann etwas mehr
für unsere Schokoriegionen,
und bei diesen Karten haben wir uns dann auch schon ein bisschen gewöhnt.
Ja, in der Regel ...
Jo, Max, was sagst du zum Angelcamp?
Ich hab da am Anfang schon was zu gesagt.
Ich persönlich kann die Begeisterung nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Wirkt auf mich im Prinzip wie RTL auf Twitch.
Wem es gefällt, schön.
Das ist aktuell die beste Option für uns,
auch wenn das, wie gesagt, leider immer noch nicht garantiert,
dass die Schokolade frei von Kinderarbeit ist.
Auf der einen Seite das Snickers für einen Euro von der Tankstelle,
auf der anderen ein ...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der Kurs ist 3,50, nicht ein Euro.
In der Elfenbeinküste.
Dazwischen findet man wahnsinnig viel Ungerechtigkeit
und scheinheilige Unternehmen, die davon profitieren.
Sie versuchen mit aller Macht, sich vor der Verantwortung
für das Leid von Millionen von Kindern zu drücken.
Bisher leider mit Erfolg.
Wenn dein Kumpel das nächste Mal zur Diva wird,
überzeug ihn doch einfach von einer zertifizierten Variante.
Und der Hunger ist gegessen.
Cheers.
Okay.
Hey, hoffentlich hat euch das Video gefallen.
Schreibt uns eure Meinung zu dem Thema in die Kommentare.
Eine Woche Vollzeit-Streamer und verdienen.
Äh ...
Wer will schon Vollzeit-Streamer werden?
So.
Wie lang bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
Alter, fast drei Stunden.
Was soll ich noch gucken?
Warum kein Samsung kaufen solltest, oder wie?
Nee.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Schau dir mal Urban Dictionary an. Kenn ich.
Das COD-Video zum Abschluss.
Okay.
Guck, gibt's da irgendwas anderes?
Ein Mittel gegen Unzufriedenheit.
Kurz gesagt, ist auch immer nice, das kommt man so an.
Unzufrieden. Alle sind unzufrieden.
Es sind nicht alle nur unzufrieden, es sind alle dann auch dabei,
der restlichen Welt mitzuteilen, wie unzufrieden sie sind.
Mit allem.
Mit allem unzufrieden.
Und dann auf Twitter gehen und erst mal sich schön empören
und sich aufregen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Wir gucken jetzt noch, ja.
Kurz gesagt, die machen immer gute Videos.
Big-Brain-Videos.
Barbecue-Pit-Boys.
Uh, uh.
Hell yeah.
Erst mal das hier.
PP-Hands.
Manchmal kommt es einem vor, als wäre man derjenige,
der sich das nicht richtig anfühlt.
PP-Hands.
Manchmal kommt es einem vor, als wäre man derjenige,
der sich das nicht richtig anfühlt.
Manchmal kommt es einem vor, als wäre man nicht erfolgreich genug.
Die Beziehung nicht glücklich genug.
Und das hätte man einfach nicht, das, wonach man sich sehnt.
Welche Beziehung?
Eine chronische Unzufriedenheit,
die uns mit Neid auf andere blicken lässt.
Und mit Enttäuschung auf uns selbst.
Popkultur, Werbung und soziale Medien machen es noch schlimmer.
Laut ihnen muss dich dein Job zu 100 Prozent erfüllen.
Du musst ständig großartige Erfahrungen sammeln,
dem Schönheitsideal entsprechen, einen Haufen Freunde haben,
und deinen Seelenverwandten finden.
Scheinbar für ...
Muss man nicht wirklich, also ...
Man kann auch einfach, äh ...
auf Twitch den Livestream anmachen und, äh ...
Poggers Emote spammen.
Und alle anderen genauso ein Leben und sind total glücklich.
Und natürlich sorgt der Selbstoptimierungstrend dafür,
dass du dich so fühlst, als müsstest du nur hart genug an dir arbeiten,
um das alles auch zu erreichen.
Ja.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen was, was ich auch schon seit Anfang,
also, was ich schon in vielen YouTube-Videos kritisiert habe,
dass es so viele Videos gibt, so nach dem Motto, ähm ...
Also, die so komplett unrealistische Dinger erzählen,
so nach dem Motto, ja, äh ...
Guckt, guckt das an, ich hab das geschafft,
und ihr könnt das auch schaffen, ihr müsst nur da dran glauben,
und es ist ganz einfach.
Die meisten, das ist nicht einfach, je nachdem, was man haben will.
Ja.
Und viele Leute haben Träume, die sie nie erreichen werden.
Ich mein, man sollte auch mal der Realität ins Auge schauen, ja.
Also, wenn ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, ich bin jetzt ...
36 fast, so, und wenn ich jetzt sag, keine Ahnung,
ich möchte mal, ähm ...
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas total bescheuert.
Also, ich möchte mal 100 Meter Weltrekord laufen.
Das ist ...
Das ist Schwachsinn, ja.
Man muss schon gucken, dass das Ganze irgendwo realisiert wird.
Also, dass das Ganze irgendwo realistisch ist.
Und, ähm ...
Ja, also, manche Sachen sind so voll ...
Wie soll man das beschreiben?
So, so, irgendwie so ...
Philosophie light irgendwie, so nach dem Motto,
ja, glaub an dich, und oh, du kannst alles schaffen, yeah, super.
Am besten kommst du noch in die Telegram- oder in die WhatsApp-Gruppe.
Ähm ...
Ja, war immer.
Wichtig, und das ...
Ich bin jetzt 35, ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Jahre hinter mir,
ja, es kommen hoffentlich noch ein paar.
Das Wichtigste, und was viele Leute, glaube ich zumindest,
noch nicht, ähm ...
auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, was auch ein bisschen braucht.
Viele sagen, dass sie das so denken, denken's aber nicht wirklich,
ist, dass man richtig Boomer, richtig Boomer, genau.
Ist erstens, dass man weniger drauf gibt, am besten gar nix.
Ähm, wie andere das finden, was man macht.
Und das geht nur,
weil man irgendwie mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden ist.
Oder sich zumindest so akzeptiert, wie man ist.
So.
Das dauert, das dauert, ja.
Ähm, man denkt immer, man muss irgendwie ein bisschen rumdoktern,
irgendwas machen, weil man weiß ja nicht, wie das Ganze ankommt
und was irgendwelche Leute drüber denken.
Und wie kann das sein, dass man das nicht mag,
obwohl es doch 90 Prozent der Leute auch mögen.
Nein, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich hab zum Beispiel früher immer gedacht,
ich bin nicht normal, weil ...
Also, an vielen ... wegen vielen Sachen, ja.
Aber zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel ...
Ich hatte immer den Eindruck,
es gehen alle voll gerne auf die Weihnachtsfeier auf der Arbeit.
So, als Beispiel jetzt mal, ja.
Und ich hasse Weihnachtsfeiern.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht ab.
Ich mag auch keinerlei, ähm, irgendwelche Sommerfeste, Events
oder andere Dinger.
Also, ich mag generell soziale Aktivitäten mit Leuten,
die ich nicht unbedingt ...
die ich nicht kenne, nicht mag, nicht sonst was, mag ich nicht, ja.
So. Da hab ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Und ich hatte immer den Eindruck, so nach dem Motto,
ey, das ist doch nicht normal.
Einfach, Olli, zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Ich dachte immer früher, das ist doch nicht normal.
Guck mal, auf der Arbeit freuen sich alle immer.
Wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Nein, ist nicht so.
Viele haben da auch keinen Bock drauf.
Nur, die sagen's dir nicht.
Ja? Pff. Die sagen's dir nicht.
Es gibt genug, die das auch kacke finden.
Und mittlerweile hab ich mich damit abgefunden,
dass ich so, ähm, soziale Events nicht abkann.
Und ich sag den Leuten mittlerweile schon, ey,
das ist nix für mich.
Äh, liegt nicht an euch, aber ich mag so Dinger nicht.
Und die verstehen das.
Die verstehen das.
Es ist besser, äh,
wenn du einfach sagst, was Sache ist,
anstatt dass du da mitgehst und den Eindruck vermittelst,
du hast keinen Bock auf die Leute.
Also, am besten ist, man sagt's.
Und die meisten Leute verstehen das auch.
Wenn du sagst, hey, so große Menschenansammlungen
mit vielen Leuten, das ist nix für mich.
Dann sagen die Leute, ah, okay, wusste ich nicht.
Dann weiß ich ja, weshalb du da immer nicht hingehst.
Vollkommen, also, es ist bis jetzt noch nicht einmal passiert,
dass irgendwie einer mir das ausreden wollte.
Also, jetzt ernsthaft, ja?
Einfach sagen, wie es ist. Einfach sagen, wie es ist.
Ja.
Und ...
das ist, glaub ich, eine Sache,
wo viele Leute eine Weile für brauchen,
dass sie sich damit abfinden können,
dass sie halt so sind, wie sie sind.
Ja.
Und es heißt jetzt nicht,
wenn einem irgendwas total auf den Keks geht an sich selbst, ja,
dass man da nix ändern kann.
Aber die Sache ist halt die,
man muss nix an sich ändern,
nur weil irgendjemand anderem das nicht gefällt
und man ein schlechtes Gewissen bekommt,
so nach dem Motto, oh, das gefällt anderen nicht,
wenn man das selbst so sieht, dann ist es was anderes.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man pepofett ist.
Ja.
Und man sich selbst sagt, ey, ich will nicht mehr pepofett sein.
Dann ist es okay.
Dann kann man sagen, okay, ich mach jetzt was,
dass ich nicht mehr pepofett bin.
Aber dann ist ja man selbst der Antrieb dahinter.
Ja.
Und natürlich kann der Auslöser unter anderem sein,
dass, äh, das vielleicht in ...
dass du blöde Kommentare kriegst oder sonst wo.
Aber das sorgt ...
meiner Erfahrung nach,
blöde Kommentare von anderen Leuten eher nicht dazu,
dass man da langfristig in irgendwas motiviert ist.
Man muss das selbst, man muss das selbst wollen.
Und bei vielen Sachen ist es halt einfach so,
es muss einem mit der Zeit einfach ziemlich egal sein,
ähm, was da andere Leute erzählen.
Sonst machst du dir den ganzen ...
Ich kenn das von früher noch.
Du machst dir quasi im Prinzip den halben Tag Gedanken irgendwie über was,
was andere Leute gesagt haben.
Wo die sich selbst keine Gedanken drüber gemacht haben.
Das ist total bescheuert.
Das ist total, total beknackt, ja.
Ähm, und man muss sich einfach auch damit abfinden,
dass die Welt voller Spasten ist.
Es gibt, also ...
70 Prozent der Leute sind Deppen.
Nicht bewusst.
Nicht bewusst, aber ...
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, weil die Leute sagen,
Alter, ich möchte jetzt, äh, ich möchte in den Arsch sein oder so.
Das passt einfach nicht.
Zu einem selbst, ja.
Und, ja, es gibt auch Leute, die machen absichtlich auf Arsch, ja, klar.
Ähm, aber die meisten Leute sind halt so, wie sie sind.
Und ich denk mir halt, Alter, was für Spasten, ja.
Und sind halt 70 Prozent der Leute.
Das denken die ...
Übrigens, das denken die anderen dann auch.
Ja, die denken sich, warum ist der Max so bescheuert?
Oder warum ist der ... Was will der überhaupt?
Ist normal, ja.
So, gucken wir erst mal weiter.
... ist die positive Psychologie entstanden.
Sie erforscht, was das Leben lebenswert macht.
Außerdem wurde die kognitive Verhaltenstherapie entwickelt,
um negativen Gefühlen ...
Was das Leben lebenswert macht, ist eigentlich aus meiner Sicht total einfach.
Möglichst viel Zeit damit verbringen, was einem Spaß macht.
Das ist eigentlich alles.
... gegenzuwirken.
Wissenschaftler stellten sich die Frage, warum sind manche Menschen
glücklicher und zufriedener als andere?
Können wir von dem lernen, was sie automatisch richtig machen?
In diesem Video geht es um eines der wichtigsten Anzeichen ...
Twitch, Twitch gucken.
... wie glücklich wir sind, wie leicht es uns fällt, Freunde zu finden ...
Oh, gar nicht.
Ich hasse alle anderen Menschen, außer den Twitch-Chat.
Dankbarkeit.
Nur der Twitch-Chat ist das Einzige, was ich mir geben kann.
Dankbarkeit mag wie ein weiterer Selbstverbesserungstrend klingen,
der vom Hashtag-Volk gepredigt wird.
Aber tatsächlich basieren alle Erkenntnisse in diesem Bereich
auf zahlreichen Studien.
Links dazu findest du in der Videobeschreibung.
Dankbarkeit kann für jeden Menschen und in jeder Lebenslage etwas anderes bedeuten.
Sie ist ein Charakterzug, ein Gefühl, eine Tugend und eine Verhaltensweise.
Man kann sie jemandem gegenüber empfinden, der etwas Nettes getan hat,
aber zum Beispiel auch für das Wetter, die Natur oder eine glückliche Fügung.
Und sie ist fest in unseren Genen verankert.
Wie Dankbarkeit uns miteinander verbindet.
Vor der Dankbarkeit gab es zunächst das Prinzip der Gegenseitigkeit.
Eine bei Tieren angeborene Motivation, Dinge zum gegenseitigen Vorteil zu tauschen.
Dieses Verhalten findet man bei manchen Fischen, Vögeln, Säugetieren und vor allem bei Primaten.
Wenn dein Gehirn feststellt, dass jemand etwas Nettes für dich getan hat,
reagiert es mit Dankbarkeit und motiviert dich so dazu, dich zu revanchieren.
Das hilft dafür, dass wir uns um andere kümmern.
Es geht um uns, eine sehr wichtige Entwicklung.
Denn als das menschliche Gehirn mit der Zeit lernte, die Gefühle anderer besser zu deuten,
wurden egoistische Individuen schnell identifiziert.
Das stimmt aber echt. Das stimmt, das stimmt aber echt.
Manchmal kommt man mit einfach nett sein ...
Also, kommt man besser rum, als mit, äh, Leute ankacken.
Zum Beispiel fällt mir eine Sache jetzt direkt ein.
Ähm, zum Beispiel, wir haben auf der Arbeit ...
Oder hatten wir das jetzt schon ein bisschen her, äh, was sich um, äh, VMs kümmert.
Ist jetzt im Prinzip auch egal, was die machen.
Und ich hab mal Tee online bestellt und da war so eine Probepackung dabei.
Und ich bin bei denen mal vorbeigegangen und hab dem einen quasi die Probepackung mitgebracht
und hab gesagt, hier, ich hab was für euch,
weil ihr euch immer so schön um unsere Linux-VMs kümmert.
Das war ... war eigentlich nette Geste, ja?
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit mir los war. Also, normalerweise würd ich so was ja nicht machen.
Wisst ihr ja, also, das ist ja viel zu zwischenmenschlich, ja?
Zumindest, ähm, hab ich das dem einen gegeben.
Und ihr glaubt das nicht, das hat er mir jahrelang erzählt.
Und er hat sich jedes Mal, wenn ich dort ein Ticket aufgemacht hab oder irgendwas wollte,
hat der sich sofort drum gekümmert.
Also, man sieht, ähm, dass man mit solchen Sachen manchmal einfacher irgendwie da ...
Was heißt zum Ziel? Zum Ziel wird ja heißen, ich hab das irgendwie berechnet oder so. Hab ich nicht, ja?
Ähm, dass man einfacher Sachen bekommt, wenn man einfach nur nett ist.
Manchmal, manchmal.
Als wenn man nur den ganzen Tag die Leute anscheißt.
Das ist das, das ist das, was man so im Großen und Ganzen, glaub ich, als Nächsten liebe,
wenn man da jetzt mal irgendwie christlich wird, äh, zusammenfasst oder generell, so, so.
Könnt man das, glaub ich, so sagen.
Also, also, eigentlich nicht meine Stärke, so wirklich, ja.
... mit anderen gutzustellen, verschaffte uns also einen Evolutionsvorteil.
Hatte ein Mensch zum Beispiel Hunger
und jemand zeigte ihm einen Platz mit leckeren Beeren,
hat er ihm gegenüber Dankbarkeit empfunden.
Es entstand eine Verpflichtung, den Gefallen zu erwidern.
Und danach, und danach ...
gab's Gatschi-Bass ...
und ganz viele kleine, neuen, äh, Steinzeitmenschen.
... mit einer Motivation, sich sozial zu verhalten.
Wurde der Gefallen schließlich erwidert, empfand das Gegenüber wieder Dankbarkeit.
Dieses Prinzip ...
hat unsere Vorfahren eng zusammengeschweißt.
Diese frühen Formen der Dankbarkeit waren biologische Mechanismen,
die unser Verhalten kooperativ gemacht haben
und den Menschen dabei geholfen haben, die Erde zu erobern.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit ist aus Dankbarkeit ...
Oh, Elmo, du hast recht.
Stimmt, stimmt, falsches, falsches E-Mode.
Ich hab aber, ich hab aber dafür kein anderes E-Mode.
... von Dankbarkeit.
Wissenschaftlern zufolge regt Dankbarkeit im Gehirn
für Belohnungen und soziale Bindungen an
und verbessert außerdem unsere Fähigkeit,
die Absichten anderer zu deuten.
Dankbarkeit wirkt sogar direkt negativ ...
Die haben immer so, die haben immer so gute Animationen, ne?
Also, das ist wirklich Big Brain, wer da die Animationen erstellt.
... entgegen, wie zum Beispiel Neid, Vergleichsdrang,
Narzissmus, Zynismus und Materialismus.
Menschen, die egal wofür dankbar sind,
neigen deshalb dazu, glücklicher und zufriedener zu sein.
Sie führen glücklichere Beziehungen und finden schneller Freunde.
Sie schlafen besser, sind weniger anfällig für Depressionen,
Sucht und Burnout und können obendrein noch besser
mit traumatischen Ereignissen umgehen.
In gewisser Weise schützt Dankbarkeit dich davor,
in eine der psychischen Fallen zu tappen,
die das moderne Leben dir stellt.
Zum Beispiel wirkt Dankbarkeit messbar der Tendenz entgegen,
Positives zu vergessen oder herunterzutreten.
Chat, ich bin so dankbar, dass ihr alle da seid.
...
Guck mal, ob ich heute Nacht besser schlafen kann.
... nach langer, harter Arbeit erreichst,
kann sich das Leer und Bedeutungslose anfühlen.
Du findest dich emotional da wieder, wo du angefangen hast
und versuchst, Befriedigung im nächsten großen Ziel zu finden,
anstatt zufrieden mit dir selbst zu sein.
Oder stell dir vor, du bist einsam und wünschst dir mehr Freunde.
Vielleicht gibt es in deinem Leben sogar einen oder mehrere Menschen,
die gerne Zeit mit dir verbringen würden.
Aber dir kommt es vor, als wäre das nicht genug.
Du siehst dich als Versager, bist mit dir selbst nicht im Reinen.
Du schlägst ihre Einladung aus und wirst noch einsamer.
Wenn du allerdings dankbar für die Beziehungen bist, die du hast,
sagst du vielleicht häufiger mal zu oder ergreifst sogar selbst die Initiative.
Nee.
Je mehr du es riskierst, dich zu öffnen,
Nee, ich will mit den anderen gar nichts zu tun haben.
... ist die Chance, Beziehungen zu vertiefen
und neue Leute kennenzulernen.
Im besten Fall wird durch Dankbarkeit eine positive Rückkopplung ausgelöst.
Positive Gefühle führen zu sozialem Verhalten,
was zu noch weiteren positiven sozialen Erfahrungen führt
und wieder positive Gefühle auslöst.
Das kommt häufig nach besonders schweren Phasen im Leben,
wie zum Beispiel einer Chemotherapie, vor.
Dann kann sich das Leben plötzlich ganz großartig anfühlen.
Die kleinste Sache kann...
Alles, alle sind so richtig happy.
... die Fähigkeit zu schmecken, einfach in der Sonne zu sitzen
oder mit einem Freund zu plaudern.
Objektiv betrachtet ist dein Leben dasselbe wie...
Ich muss mal wieder mit dem Friseur telefonieren, fällt mir gerade ein.
Oder Dis... Discon... Discon... Callen.
... ein bisschen schlechter.
Aber dein Gehirn vergleicht deine aktuellen Erfahrungen mit Zeiten,
in denen das Leben schwieriger war, und reagiert mit Dankbarkeit.
Kurz gesagt, Dankbarkeit richtet deine Aufmerksamkeit verstärkt
auf die guten Dinge in deinem Leben.
Die Folge, positive Gefühle und Erfahrungen...
Zockt ja immer noch BDO.
Nee, ich hab gehört, da spielt jetzt Diablo auf der Switch gerade.
Muss ich mir auch denken, was ist da los?
Aber wie kann man mehr Dankbarkeit empfinden?
Wie du dein Gehirn zur Dankbarkeit...
Ganz einfach, mehr Twitch-Donations.
Mehr Prime-Subs, mehr Prime-Subs.
... Lagung zur Dankbarkeit.
Es gibt individuelle Unterschiede.
Sie kann entweder stärker oder schwächer ausgeprägt sein.
Das hängt von Genen, der Persönlichkeit und dem kulturellen Umfeld ab.
Wissenschaftler wollten herausfinden, ob es möglich ist,
an dieser Dankbarkeitsveranlagung
und damit auch an der Zufriedenheit zu arbeiten.
Bevor wir hier tiefer einsteigen, sollten wir erwähnen,
dass noch nicht ganz geklärt ist, in welchem Maße
und wie nachhaltig Dankbarkeit trainiert werden kann.
Es gibt leider keine magischen Glückspillen.
Das Leben ist kompliziert.
An manchen Tagen hat man das Gefühl, alles im Griff zu haben.
Und an anderen Tagen eben nicht. Und das ist okay.
Und manchmal, wenn du dich selbst zu sehr unter Druck setzt,
kann das Streben nach Glück dich auch unglücklicher machen.
Aber Dankbarkeit hat nichts zu tun,
denn Dankbarkeit allein ist kein Heilmittel für Depressionen
und kann professionelle Hilfe nicht ersetzen.
Sie ist nur ein Puzzleteilchen im Gesamtbild der mentalen Gesundheit.
Die einfachste Dankbarkeitsmethode mit fundierter wissenschaftlicher Basis
ist das Dankbarkeitstagebuch.
Man muss sich nur ...
Was?
... ein- bis dreimal pro Woche für ein paar Minuten Zeit nehmen
und fünf bis zehn Dinge aufschreiben, für die man dankbar ist.
Vielleicht fühlt sich das komisch an. Fang deshalb mit etwas Leichtem an.
Kannst du für etwas Kleines dankbar sein?
Vielleicht dafür, wie gut Kaffee schmeckt?
Oder dafür, dass jemand freundlich zu dir ...
Ich mag keinen Kaffee.
... hat jemand etwas Nettes für dich getan?
Oder fallen dir Menschen oder Dinge ein, die dir fehlen würden,
wenn sie plötzlich weg wären und für die du dankbar sein kannst?
Jeder Mensch ist anders.
Finde heraus, was sich für dich gut anfühlt.
Und das war's schon. Ehrlich. Es klingt beinahe lächerlich.
Eigentlich dürfte das nicht so einfach sein.
Aber in zahlreichen Studien haben Probanden berichtet,
dass sie sich glücklicher und allgemein zufriedener fühlen,
nachdem sie diese Übung ...
Wir sollten dankbar für Snickers sein, hab ich jetzt gehört im letzten Beitrag.
Studien konnten außerdem noch einige Monate später ...
Sandoor! 385, drei Monate. Exzellent Subscription.
Ich bin sehr dankbar für diesen Prime-Sub.
... der Hirnaktivität feststellen.
Dankbarkeitsübungen können dich also tatsächlich umprogrammieren.
Dadurch wird deutlich,
dass Gefühle und Stimmungen nicht in Stein gemeißelt sind.
Wie du das Leben wahrnimmst, beruht am Ende nur darauf, wie du es anordnest.
Veränderst du im Kern, wie du über dich selbst und das Leben denkst,
veränderst du damit deine Gedanken und Gefühle und damit auch ...
Oh, jetzt wird's aber big brain, ja.
Es ist unglaublich, dass etwas so Simples wie Selbstreflexion
die Verknüpfungen im Gehirn so ändern und damit Unzufriedenheit bekämpfen kann.
Das stimmt. Also mal, das würde echt vielen Leuten guttun.
Einfach mal, wenn die sich mal ...
... Gedanken drüber machen würden, was sie eigentlich machen.
Ja, das, das würde sicherlich einigen helfen.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt glücklicher zu werden, aber weniger Blödsinn zu machen.
Wenn das mal kein Grund für Optimismus ist, was dann?
Ein Mensch zu sein ist schwer, aber man muss es sich nicht schwerer machen als nötig.
Geh ein bisschen aufmerksamer durchs Leben und du wirst viele Dinge bemerken,
die es schon jetzt schöner machen.
Das würde den ganzen Hate Speech Leuten auf Twitter mal guttun.
Oder was heißt Hate Speech Leuten?
Ich verwende das Wort ja eigentlich so ungern.
Den ganzen Empörungsleuten auf Twitter würde das echt mal guttun,
sich ein bisschen umzugucken.
Wie sagt man so schön, aus ihrer Filterblase mal rauszugehen.
Da wird nächsten Monat wieder gesubbt. Excellent.
Twitter ist voller PP-Gas, ja.
Was, hast du die neue Webseite von ...
Wie spricht man den eigentlich aus?
Rezo gesehen?
Nee, äh, mich interessiert aber auch die Webseite von Rezo nicht sonderlich.
Was ist das von Rezo?
Nindo.
Okay.
Social Media Charts und Statistiken.
Und warum genau ist das jetzt eine Webseite von Rezo?
Weil er da oben steht oder was?
Weil er sich selbst feiern will oder wie oder was?
Hä?
Neues Social Blade.
Kann man ... Okay, Moment.
Ich such mal nach mir, mal gucken, was da passiert.
Oh, guck mal, mich gibt's.
Oh, RIP.
MonkaS.
FeelsBadMan.
Ähm ...
Tweets, Retweets.
Durchschnitt nach fünf Tagen.
Pro Tweet 137 Likes, 12 Comments, zwei Retweets.
Ein Prozent, bam.
Ja, interessiert keine Sauerstoffpost, ja.
Moment, ist das jetzt Twi ... Ah, das ist Twitter.
Ah, ah, ah.
Excellent.
Wo bloß?
Hier, es geht steil bergauf.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, gut, ich hab jetzt ja nicht gestreamt die letzten Tage.
Ähm ...
Oh, hier.
Twitter-Rang.
Moment, wenn ich auf Twitch ...
Okay, das ist jetzt natürlich ...
Da geht natürlich nix.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wirklich besser als Social Blade
ist es jetzt auch nicht, ne?
Dem fehlt vor allem die Langzeit-Statistik,
die Social Blade hat.
Dieser Kanal ist nicht aktiv genug,
um einen außerhalb kräftigen Rang zu erreichen.
Ja, ist so.
Twitch-Rang.
Guck mal hier, was haben wir denn da?
Neue Follower.
Was ist das?
Okay, das ist so ein typisches Web-Design-Ding,
wo man keine Ahnung hat, das sind irgendwas mit Zuschauern.
Das sind ...
Sind das Durchschnittszuschauer und Top-Zuschauer?
Auf geht's, 13 Monate, exzellent.
Dankeschön.
Um nichts zu sagen.
Das sind Top- und das sind Durchschnittszuschauer.
Das sind neue Follower, okay.
Typische Stream-Zeit, ah, das ist interessant.
Manchmal, ja, das sind die Sonntags-Streams.
Und das ist nach der Arbeit, ja.
Genau, genau, trifft's ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Typische Stream-Tage, also man sieht, ich bin ...
Ich bin am Wochenende motivierter als unter der Woche.
Aha. Na gut.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Donnerstag-Streams, ja.
Naja, unter der Woche ist ja klar, wenn ich arbeiten gehe,
dass ich da weniger streamen soll.
Deswegen bist du Donnerstag-depressiv.
Da musst du einfach nur denken, was wir gerade im Video gelernt hast.
Du musst ein Dankbarkeitstagebuch führen,
und dann bist du wieder gut drauf.
Pineapple-Salsa-Spare Ribs. Ich hab Hunger, Leute.
Noch die Barbecue-Pit-Boys. Okay.
Pineapple-Salsa-Spare-Ribs-Recipe.
Okay. Das gucken wir noch.
Exzellent.
Hell yeah.
Kokona.
Welcome to BBQ-Pit-Boys.com.
Today we're grilling up some pineapple-salsa-spare-Ribs.
Ah, yes.
And it's real easy to do. All right.
We have a rack of spare ribs here.
Yeah.
Hey, guys.
Ich hab das Ding.
Warnung. Für Veganer ist das jetzt nix.
You're gonna need some ingredients like salt, paprika, black pepper...
Paprika. Paprika brauchen wir immer.
Da steht was von Fachinformatik. Da müssen wir auch anschauen.
Das sind noch Sachen, die ich vom letzten Mal übrig hatte.
Fachinformatik-Kommentar 2012. Wer will denn so was gucken?
Okay. Das geht nur drei Minuten. Das gucken wir schnell noch.
Das gucken wir schnell noch.
Fachinformatik, das ist von 2012.
Oh, das ist ein Werbevideo für eine Firma.
Okay, das ist bestimmt Fail.
Das ist bestimmt Fail.
Das ist bestimmt richtig Fremdschämen-Video.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Cringe, richtig Cringe.
Massive Cringe wahrscheinlich.
Überleg mal, das war 2018.
Der Typ war da irgendwie 22, jetzt ist er 30.
Nein, nicht abgelesen.
Nicht abgelesen.
Wir hatten den Sound wieder abgemischt.
Computer und Programme haben mich schon während meiner Kindheit interessiert.
Oh, hier Putti.
Putti.
Das ist bestimmt Putti, hä?
Ist das Putti? Ich erkenne es gerade nicht genau.
Anders als zu Hause,
wo er sich nur um seine...
...eigenen Rechner kümmern muss,
betreut er...
Was ist mit der Sprecherin los?
...um seinen eigenen Rechner kümmern...
...eigenen Rechner kümmern muss.
Was ist das für eine Sprecherin los?
...sich nur um seinen eigenen Rechner kümmern muss,
betreut er hier bei IWIS hunderte von unterschiedlichen...
...Hardware-Komponenten,
installiert Programme,
konfiguriert ganze Systeme
und kümmert sich...
Windows XP am Start.
...wünsche der IWIS-Mitarbeiter überall im Betrieb.
Als Systemadministrator
kümmere ich mich um das Netzwerk...
Volle Motivation!
...Computer, Drucker und Bildschirme
in allen Abteilungen laufen
und auch die rechnergestützten Produktionen...
Die Drucker und Bildschirme, oh Gott, ich kriege Anfälle.
...zu meinem Aufgabengebiet.
...sagt Marco Thiele, sein Vorgesetzter und Ausbilder,
der nun bereits...
Ach, das ist der Vorgesetzte und Ausbilder,
kein Wunder, dass die alle so motiviert sind.
...vielen Jahren in diesem Beruf tätig ist.
Heute profitiert er von dem,
was er während seiner Ausbildung gelernt hat
und trägt eine große Verantwortung.
Oh, er kann Druckerpatrone wechseln.
Oh Gott, huge.
Diese massive Verantwortung für Druckerpatronen,
die kenne ich, wer kennt die nicht, ja?
Ich, ich, ich, ich spüre die jedes Mal.
...Informatiker pflegen nicht nur die Hard- und Software von Computern,
sondern auch die IT-Systeme der großen Produktionsanlagen
und Maschinen in der Fertigung von IWIS.
Okay, das ist natürlich schon eine gewisse Verantwortung.
...ob der Wechsel von Druckerpatronen
oder die Installation eines neuen Bildschirms.
Der Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration,
spielt eine wichtige Rolle im Unternehmen,
denn er hält...
Installation eines neuen Bildschirms,
weil man da auch so viel für machen muss.
...laufen.
Konzentration und Ausdauer gehören ebenso
zu der abwechslungsreichen Aufgabe
wie gute Grundkenntnisse im Umgang mit Computern und Programmen.
Wenn du dich hier wieder findest,
dann ist diese Berufsausbildung genau das richtige...
Das ist wenigstens mal ein schöner Patch-Schrank.
So ist doch gut.
Ja, das ist wenigstens,
das ist wenigstens wie in der Realität, Alter.
Das sieht nirgendwo so ordentlich aus,
wie in den Werbevideos immer.
Doch so sieht das in der Realität aus.
...genau das Richtige für dich.
Und hier nochmal die Fakten im Überblick.
Wurde euer Bahnticket in der Ausbildung
vom Arbeitgeber übernommen?
Nee.
Die Berufsausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
für Systemintegration dauert drei Jahre.
Du gehst während dieser Zeit nicht nur in den Betrieb,
sondern auch in die Berufsschule, wo der Blog und...
Welcher High-IQ-Mensch,
hat dieses Ding hier gespielt, Miriam?
Aber dieses Spiel kannst du eigentlich gar nicht verlieren.
...Unterricht stattfindet.
Du solltest mindestens die mittlere Reife erlangt haben
und fit in Sachen Computer...
Und was macht die Fahrradkette da?
...im ersten Lehrjahr bei 814 Euro pro Monat.
Moment, das ist kein Bild,
der steht wirklich da.
Fuck, Mann, der steht da.
...drei Jahre.
Das ist kein Foto,
da steht wirklich ne Minute da und bewegt sich nicht.
Du gehst während dieser Zeit nicht nur in den Betrieb,
sondern auch in die Berufsschule,
wo der Blogunterricht stattfindet.
Guck mal, der bewegt sich.
Du solltest mindestens die mittlere Reife erlangt haben
und fit in Sachen Computer sein.
Die Vergütung liegt schon im ersten Lehrjahr
bei 814 Euro pro Monat
und steigert sich sogar...
Der steht immer noch da.
Also, mach es wie Felix und komm zu Ibis.
Das familiengeführte Unternehmen produziert Steuerketten
für die Autoindustrie...
Ach.
Ach, deswegen ist da ne Kette drauf gewesen.
...in der Welt.
Ibis ist Marktführer in seinem Segment...
Das Gelaber immer von wegen Marktführer.
Das machen sie alle.
Das machen sie echt alle.
...entwickeln die Mitarbeiter die Ketten
und Antriebssysteme ständig weiter.
Die hohe Qualität...
Sieht aus wie beim Dönermann.
...und weiter.
Sieht bissl aus wie beim Dönermann.
Die hohe Qualität und Zuverlässigkeit
beginnt schon in der Produktion...
Okay, das vielleicht nicht.
Außer er hat DER Gerät.
...des Herstellprozesses Stück für Stück
zu einer kompletten Kette zusammengefügt werden.
Dazu werden supermoderne Maschinen,
Roboter und Computer...
Supermodern.
...bedient von gut ausgebildeten
und zuverlässigen Mitarbeitern,
die oftmals schon bei Ibis
ihre Berufsausbildung gemacht haben.
Wenn du also einen zuverlässigen Zukunfts...
Wie jeder Roboter bietet auch ein Dönerroboter
handfeste Vorteile.
...findet der Hersteller.
Der Gerät wird nie müde.
Der Gerät schläft nie ein.
Der Gerät ist immer vor dem Chef im Geschäft.
Und schneidet das Fleisch schweißfrei.
Und schneidet das Dönerfleisch schweißfrei.
Genau.
Besser.
Wie?
Wahrscheinlich gäbs heute Diskussionen drüber,
ob das nicht ein rassistischer Clip war oder so.
Aber der ist geiler Typ.
Das Ding heißt ja wirklich der Gerät mittlerweile.
Man kann das kaufen unter der Gerät.
Okay.
Kokona Video.
Gucken ob's am Grill.
Ah, yes.
They have an Adobo sauce.
We got some salsa.
We got some apple cider vinegar.
One Monte.
We got some tequila.
What?
We got some pineapple.
Here we got some chopped onions.
Some garlic.
Some brown sugar.
And here we got some Chipotle and adobo sauce.
To kick it up a notch.
Adobo sauce?
Adobe sauce?
Was für ein Ding?
Was?
Was für eine Sauce?
Some onions, some garlic, some brown sugar.
And here we got some chipotle and adobo sauce.
What is this?
What?
Und hier haben wir ein bisschen Chipotle und Adobo-Sauce.
Adobo-Sauce.
Okay, es gibt nicht viel Vorbereitung, die man mit diesem Rack machen muss.
Es ist wie ein ganzer Rack.
Wir schneiden das Fleisch, glaube ich, viel zu lange raus.
Das hat manchmal schon so komische Farbe.
Ich werde das so machen, weil das Fleisch von seiner Natur anders gekocht wird als das Fleisch mit den Bohnen.
Also schneiden wir das einfach raus, damit wir etwas evenes Kochen bekommen.
Und wir kochen das Flap separat.
Okay, jetzt schneiden wir dieses Ende ab.
Und es sieht ziemlich cool aus.
Wir werden das Membran auf dem Hintergrund schießen.
Und es gibt eine Unterschiede in der Meinung zu diesem.
Einige werden das Membran entfernen, viele Revisen werden es behalten.
Wir werden es einfach schießen lassen, um einige der Saison zu erreichen.
Jetzt, bevor wir das Rack anpassen, werden wir es mit etwas Mustard anziehen.
Hier haben wir etwas Gelberes.
Benutze deinen Lieblingsmustard.
Das hilft, den Rack anzupacken, auch wenn es...
Bist du...
M-A-X-F-P-S
...sagt mir nichts.
Also, du schießt es mit diesem Rack-Blend.
Schießt es gut.
Ein bisschen mehr Mustard auf der anderen Seite.
Oh, ja.
Wer ist das?
Perfekt.
Benutze deinen Lieblingsrack, wenn du nicht...
Ja, ja, ich bin's, ich bin's, ich bin's.
Ich gebe es zu.
Ich habe das nämlich schon ein paar Mal gebetet.
Und das ging dann so weit, dass mir einer auf Twitter geschrieben hat,
dass jemand auf Twitch mein Logo verwenden würde.
Ich bin's, ich gebe es zu.
Anzeige jetzt raus.
Oh, Mann.
Wenn du noch nie Pineapple-Sauce-Sperrribs hattest,
musst du es definitiv ausprobieren.
Oder du verpasst etwas aus deiner Leben, oder?
Oh, ja.
Also, wir haben das Rack-Blend verwendet.
Schön und dick, auf beiden Seiten.
Und wir werden ein paar Kettelgrillen...
Das dem noch nicht der Bart abgefackelt ist.
... hier.
Indirekt Grillen.
Außerhalb der heißen Kohlen.
Und wir wollen die Temperatur des Grilles
in etwa 250 bis 275 Grad Fahrenheit.
Nun, während wir kochen,
machen wir die Salsa-Sauce.
Also, in die Pfanne...
Wo steht der denn?
Da drinne hier?
Wir geben ein paar gechoppte Zwiebeln rein.
Ein paar Zwiebeln.
Kochen wir es ein bisschen.
Dann geben wir die Pineapple.
Oh, jetzt.
Jetzt können wir eine frische Pineapple,
natürlich kannst du auch eine gebrannte Pineapple benutzen.
Das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Jetzt kochen wir es langsam runter.
Jetzt geben wir ein bisschen Salsa.
Und nicht schmutzig auf die Salsa.
Benutze eine gute Salsa.
Okay.
Oh.
Macht er gleich.
Oh, alles kommt zusammen.
Wir machen es mit etwas Apfelsalz oder Vanillezucker,
um es ein bisschen teurer zu machen.
Hier haben wir ein bisschen Ketchup.
Ein bisschen brauner Zucker.
Ich denke, du weißt, wo wir damit gehen.
Also, ich bin enttäuscht, dass er das mit einem Löffel mischt.
Normalerweise macht er das doch alles mit seiner Machete.
Das riecht gut.
Gut.
Hier ist die Magie.
Ein bisschen Chipotle und Adobo-Sauce.
Ein bisschen mehr Feuer und Wasser.
Und ein großartiges...
Etwas Zucker.
Etwas Zucker war das gerade.
...gebrannte Zucke.
Ein bisschen.
Ein, ein, eine...
Das war ja fast eine Messerspitze Zucker, ja.
Natürlich, mit Tequila.
So viel wie du willst.
Aber sicherlich...
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das das ist, wo das Fleisch eingelegt wird gleich.
Würde ich mal vermuten.
... für den Pitmaster.
Das ist es ja.
Okay.
Also, nach ein bisschen kochen wir es wirklich gut.
Ja.
Hier können wir uns gleich angucken noch.
Oh.
Oh, das sieht aber schon gut aus.
Muss man sagen, ne?
Äh, Chumpnick, auf YouTube tut sich da auch gerade nicht viel.
Auf YouTube habe ich, glaube ich, vor drei Monaten noch nichts gesehen.
Ich habe es gerade noch nicht gesehen.
Oh, ich glaube vor drei Monaten haben wir schon wieder ein Video hochgeladen.
...It will just make there ribs that much tender, when they are done.
So just to get even cooking, we'll just flip them around a bit.
Oh, also gut.
Ey Leute, ich würde es mir jetzt sofort rein hauen.
Ja, das sieht schon gut aus.
They look perfect.
Da fehlt noch ein bisschen Fett, weil ansonsten müssen die Sachen mindestens mal
ein halbes Päckchen Butter kriegen, bei dem.
Again, our goal is about 205 degrees Fahrenheit internal around those ribs, right?
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
And it takes a while.
It'll take a good four hours, low and slow.
But you got the time, right?
Now, we're going to do a little bit of Texas cheat.
We want to raise the temperature a little bit faster internally on this rack.
So we're going to wrap it in some aluminum foil.
This will allow it to cook just a bit faster.
Perfect.
Oh, man.
Throw them back on the grill.
Das Fleisch, das sah wirklich gut aus.
Und das sage ich als Teilzeit-Veganer.
Ich bin Veganer, solange ich kein Fleisch esse.
And in the miracle of time, I see these ribs are getting darn near done.
So.
Subscriptions werden verschenkt hier.
Nice.
Loco, dankeschön.
Excellent.
Big brain.
Okay, vorher sah das Fleisch besser aus.
Good.
Now you know there are a hundred ways to do ribs.
And this is a good one.
You gotta check it out.
Alright.
I say these ribs...
Wow.
Das sieht ein bisschen verbrannt aus.
...done.
You can see some of the meat is pulled back on those bones.
That's a good indication.
You got a good rack here.
Okay, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay, nein, das ist glaube ich doch nicht verbrannt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach die Soße, die war eigentlich schon relativ dunkel.
If you waited to about 205 degrees, where all that collagen and connective tissue and fats break down,
you're gonna get perfect ribs every time.
So, for the exact recipe,
Hey, ich würd's, ich würd's mir jetzt auch direkt gönnen.
...comment to our website.
Give us a shout-out, a thumbs-up, follow us.
So, was soll, was, was sollte ich jetzt noch mir angucken?
Also, es haben ein paar Leute Sachen geschickt.
So.
Einmal sollte ich mir noch angucken den aktuellen Stand zur Corona-App
und irgendeinen, irgendeinen Spiegel sollte ich mir noch angucken.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das mit dem Spiegel jetzt erstmal an.
Hey, what's going on guys?
This is ETA Prime back here again.
Der macht gute Videos.
Von dem habe ich schon ein paar Sachen angeguckt.
In letzter Zeit reitet er mir immer ein bisschen zu sehr auf der Welle von irgendwelchen Raspberry Pi, Raspbian Reskins, also das...
Today we're gonna be taking a look at the Hyper Mirror.
Hyper?
Gachi Hyper fällt mir höchstens ein.
Haben wir nämlich mal drinne.
...interested in for a long time.
Not the Hyper Mirror specifically, because this is a new product.
But wireless HDMI devices or wireless display devices.
Ah, ich finde das immer geil, wie sie alle HDMI, HDMI aussprechen.
Das ist ein Wireless HDMI Device.
But wireless HDMI devices or wireless display devices.
Now I've been wanting to pick one of these up for a long time.
Ein Wireless HDMI Display Device.
It's been a little overpriced and this is actually available on Kickstarter right now from $99.
Aber es ist auch Wireless Router mit HDMI Display Device.
Egal, ich mach weiter.
Von $119.
And this promises lag-free wireless display over HDMI.
Or pretty much any device that supports video over USB Type-C.
Like a lot of the new phones coming out on the market today.
So in this video we're gonna be taking a look at the Hyper Mirror.
And we're also gonna test it out with a few different devices.
Moment, das heißt einfach nur Mirror. Das hat mit Mirror nichts zu tun.
Inside of the box we have a few accessories here.
We have the Type-C Transmitter.
This also includes the HDMI Transmitter built in.
We have the HDMI Receiver.
Ach, das ist so eine Art Display Link.
Also quasi irgendwo anstöpseln und dann über Wireless übertragen und irgendwo Monitor anschließen.
We also have the User Manual here.
The HDMI Receiver Bracket.
Now this can be used to mount this on the side of your monitor or your television.
It's not totally necessary but it is included.
Ich glaube damit fange ich erst gar nicht an.
Überlegt euch mal.
Ich würde mal ein 240 Hz Bildschirm laden.
Das wäre ja irgendwie ziemlich beknackt.
240 Hz geht übrigens ähnlich über HDMI.
We also have a phone stand that's designed to hold your phone while the Type-C Transmitter is attached to it.
And they've also included all the cables that you'll need.
Ach, man überträgt von seinem Handy oder was?
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, man stöpselt das HDMI Kabel an die Ausgabe von der Grafikkarte an.
Der überträgt das Wireless und woanders dann rein.
Okay, jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Jetzt muss ich echt mal weitergucken.
... USB Type-C and a smaller USB Type-C to USB Type-C Cable.
And inside of the USB Type-C Transmitter you can actually pull the HDMI Transmitter right out of here
to use with HDMI-enabled devices like the Raspberry Pi, laptops or even game consoles.
Now when I first heard about this product I got super excited mainly for my Android devices.
I really didn't give it any more thought.
Was kostet denn sowas?
Amazon.
Amazon Hyper Mirror.
Äh, fast.
Gibt's anscheinend in Deutschland nicht.
Ach, Kickstarter.
Moment, ist der Sinn von Amazon Video nicht, dass hier nicht steht die komplette erste Staffel,
sondern steht von was die komplette erste Staffel?
Die komplette erste Staffel? Ja, von was?
Hauptsache die komplette erste Staffel.
Ach, das ist Kickstarter.
Hm.
Nachdem ich, ich, ich...
Okay, die haben für 4.000.
4.000 ist schon mal viel zu wenig.
Ich...
Seitdem die mich so gescampt haben mit der Hose,
200 Euro gescampt haben,
bin ich vorsichtig was Kickstarter-Projekte angeht.
Oder 150 Euro oder was auch immer das war, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Nachdem die mich so gescampt haben mit der selbstreinigenden Hose...
Also Leute, ich weiß.
Selbstreinigende Hose klingt erstmal lull, Max.
Wie kannst du sowas backen, ja?
Aber das war echt nicht schlecht gemacht.
Und ich hab das denen geklaut mit der selbstreinigenden Hose.
Und ich hab die selbstreinigende Hose gebackt.
Und die kam nie an.
Und die sind scamast.
Ja, ähm, Kickstarter.
Jeans.
Ja.
Das Kickstarter-Projekt ist immer noch da.
Updates.
Ja.
Das kam nie an.
So.
Und die haben damals halt geworben mit...
Also T-Shirts gab's auch, ja.
Die haben halt gesagt, sie machen irgendeine Hose mit...
aus so dreckabweisendem Material.
Und T-Shirts.
Und ich fand das klang glaubhaft, weil es gibt ja schon...
Stoffe und Sachen, die das machen.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, das wäre eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee gewesen mit der Hose.
Und ich hab dann auch hier gleich das Fette geplätscht.
Irgendwie mit T-Shirts und einer Hose.
Und es kam nie an.
Man kann pre-ordern.
Ha!
Guck mal, die Domain gibt's doch nicht mal mehr.
Vielleicht kommt da noch was.
Ja.
Ganz bestimmt kommt da noch was.
Ganz bestimmt.
Sieht genauso aus, als kommt da noch was.
Tja.
RIP, würde ich sagen.
Nun ja.
Seitdem backe ich ungern Kickstarter-Projekte.
Richtig jebaited haben sie mich.
Sie haben mich RICHTIG...
...
Ja.
So, war der richtige T-Shirt.
Lieb's?
50kgright.
Pper...
50.
60 GHz.
Das ist ja noch mehr als 5G.
Das ist ja...
das geht aber nicht. Monka W, Monka Giga, 60, ganze 60 Gigahertz. Da hilft gar nichts mehr dagegen,
außer der Ganzkörper Alufolienanzug vielleicht. Okay, Latency zero,
ist schon mal prinzipiell gelogen. Es gibt nichts mit Zero Latency,
außer Stadia, die haben negative Latency, was sie ja wirklich erzählt haben. Aber rein
physikalisch kann es keine Zero Latency geben. Unmöglich. Es ist ja im Prinzip eh nur Gbait,
dass das Ganze so läuft. Es ist ja im Prinzip nur Gbait, dass das Ganze so läuft. Es ist ja im
ganze Lichtgeschwindigkeit heißt.
Eigentlich ist es nicht Lichtgeschwindigkeit,
sondern die maximale Geschwindigkeit,
wie du Informationen austauschen kannst.
Und es ist halt zufälligerweise
auch Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Aber es muss nicht unbedingt,
es muss kein Licht sein, ja.
Es ist einfach die schnellstmögliche
Geschwindigkeit,
wie du Informationen austauschen kannst.
Und deswegen kann es nie Zero Latency
sein. Ist halt im Vergleich
zu den anderen gemeint. Ja, dann
sollte man es zumindest realistisch schreiben und halt
nicht Zero, sondern kleiner
1 ms oder sowas.
Oh, jetzt kommt der Chat.
Das ist nicht zufällig Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Jetzt habe ich was gesagt, Alter.
Jetzt geht der Chat ab.
So.
Router.
Und warum hat
er das überhaupt schon? Ah, wahrscheinlich, weil er
Kickstarter gebackt hat.
So.
Was ist das für ein wackeliges Ding?
Sieht nicht sonderlich elegant aus daneben dran.
Ich würde das lieber irgendwo
dahinter verstecken.
And like I mentioned, this will work with any device
that has HDMI out or supports
display over USB Type-C.
So there are tons of devices out there.
Schau mal, wenn YouTube jemand deine Cheats getestet hat,
kann ich gleich machen, aber ich gehe
davon aus, nicht, weil die keiner bekommen hat,
außer die Typen selbst.
I'm gonna give it a second to connect and
there it is. So yeah, I didn't have to
do any setup here. I just plugged in the
transmitter and the receiver.
It automatically went into DeX mode.
So I'm gonna swap out of DeX mode real quick.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
And here we are with just mirroring the phone itself
wirelessly. Zero latency.
I'll tell you, right now, just even
in the middle. Ich meine, auf diese
Entfernung. In you. This is super
quick. I mean, I personally don't
notice any latency here from the phone
screen to the wireless screen.
And as for range on this, 16
and a half feet with zero latency.
And I'll definitely test that out by the
end of this video. But right now, just
here with the monitor, and I know I'm not
that far away from the receiver itself,
there is no latency whatsoever.
I mean, this is working just like the phone
screen is working. I'm gonna
swap over to DeX mode.
Now, I know it works because I automatically
went into DeX mode.
But no wires connected here
to the display itself.
And if I can find the option, I'll turn
my phone into a touchpad.
And there we go. So the phone
screen is being used as a touchpad
for DeX. Also ich muss sagen, latency
sehe ich jetzt da nicht
im Video, aber ich meine auf die Entfernung.
Da geht nichts verloren
und sonst was.
This big monitor I have here.
It does come with
this little stand.
That kind of connects right into the
transmitter on the back of the phone.
And overall, I mean,
Schau mal, wo er die App wechselt. Okay, warte mal.
It does come with this little stand.
Egal, gucken wir gleich.
Ach hier.
This little phone screen itself, I'm really
not used to it. But if you want to use
something like this for DeX, it's gonna work
perfectly fine.
So I'm gonna be testing another Android phone.
This is the RedMagic 5G. It does
support display over USB Type-C.
But I wanted to get a little bit of gaming on
here and just see.
If we have any latency with fast-paced
games.
Ah, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, was da,
weil da sieht man es auf jeden Fall.
Plug it right in.
Give it a few seconds to connect and
we should see the screen from the 5G.
By the way, geht mit Apple-Geräten
natürlich nicht, ne?
Pop up on the big screen.
It does have a little LED indicator on
the back that blinks blue.
And there it is.
I'm now casting the RedMagic 5G
screen to the transmitter connected
to my HDMI 5G.
Ein bisschen Verzögerung hat das, das sieht man.
I'm gonna go ahead and look at the screen.
I'm gonna go ahead and load up a game
and we'll go with Asphalt 9.
Doch, doch, doch, guck mal, hier hat man es eben
schön gesehen, wenn man die App wechselt.
Guckt.
... and load up a game, we'll go with Asphalt 9
because it's fully updated.
Getting to some gameplay here.
Na, wobei, guckt mal, also, man sieht es ja
an den Zahlen, also ein großer Unterschied
ist da wirklich nicht.
Guckt mal, nee, nee, nee, das hat nur so gewirkt.
Guckt mal.
Also, okay, das ist jetzt ein 60 FPS Video,
keine Ahnung, mit was er das aufgenommen hat,
aber genau, also erstens, klar, könnte das
auch Monitoring, aber selbst wenn, also das ist
wirklich, natürlich ist es keine Zero Latency,
das ist klar, das habe ich ja gleich gesagt,
Zero Latency kann es ja nicht geben.
Das ist zwei Frames oder so hintendran,
keine Ahnung, das ist schon, das geht wirklich
ziemlich schnell.
Zwei, ja.
Dürften das sein.
Paar Millisekunden auf jeden Fall.
Mobile Games, lul.
Ist nicht schlecht.
Was siehst du hier?
Jemand, der sagt, du kannst vom Handy zum Fernseher
was ohne Latency übertragen, was natürlich
offensichtlich nicht geht.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich gering, die Latency,
das muss man echt sagen.
Ich habe mich entschieden, mit einem Laptop hier zu gehen.
Ich werde den vollen HDMI-Transmitter rausnehmen,
den in den HDMI-Port auf dem Laptop einbinden.
Ich sollte keine Setup machen,
das heißt, damit könnte man Diablo Immortal
auf dem PC spielen, ja, verstehe.
Und komme auf 1080p.
Und dieser Dongle unterstützt 1440p, 60 Hertz.
Und da ist er.
Nun, ich habe persönlich nie mit
irgendeinem Art von Wireless-HDMI gespürt,
also ist es ein bisschen überraschend,
um zu sehen, wie schön das hier funktioniert.
Von der Maus bis zu meinen Schlüsselstufen
auf dem Keyboard, sehe ich keine Latency hier
zwischen dem großen Bildschirm und dem Bildschirm
auf dem Laptop selbst.
Nun, das letzte Gerät, das ich hier wirklich
testen wollte, war ein Raspberry Pi,
aber unfassungslos hat der neue Raspberry Pi 4
Micro-HDMI, also muss ich
einen kleinen Adapter verwenden.
Der Use-Case, ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht, wenn du von deinem PC
was ins Wohnzimmer übertragen willst oder so,
keine Ahnung.
Also wirklich, Anwendungszweck fällt mir
jetzt auch kein guter ein.
HDMI to full size.
Got it plugged in here.
And it should automatically
detect it. And by the way,
I'm running Raspberry Pi OS here.
Na, weniger Kabel gleich einfacher,
ne, also wenn ich die Möglichkeit, ich glaube nicht,
dass das ein Ersatz für Kabel ist.
Dort, wo ich ein Kabel nehmen kann, würde ich
auch immer ein Kabel nehmen.
Weil ein Kabel auch einfach viel billiger ist
und besser funktioniert.
Allein schon der Technikwege halber.
Ähm,
das ist,
wie gesagt, das ist dort, wo
ich nah genug dran bin, aber kein Kabel machen
kann, zum Beispiel von meinem PC ins
Wohnzimmer oder so.
Basically, this will work with any HDMI enabled
device. And again,
I'm just using the mouse here.
There's no physical HDMI cable
plugged into my monitor, and I would never
be able to tell the difference here.
So I also wanted to test the latency
here, but I don't have any really expensive
equipment to do it. So what I did was just set up
my camera to record at 240
FPS, slow motion.
And we can kind of see when it pops up on each screen.
Now I've used this method in the past
to test out if you have latency.
And as you can see here at 240
FPS, I'm not noticing
any latency between the screen
on the laptop and the wireless display
we have in the background here.
And it's actually a little odd, because a few times
when I tested this, you'll see it in this video here,
it looks like it pops up first
on the wireless display.
Na, wahrscheinlich ist das der Display
einfach schneller.
Der sollte mal irgendwas zeigen, ein ordentliches Testbild zeigen,
doch nicht sowas.
Irgendwas, wo schön kontrastmäßig umgeschaltet
wird, wo man auch was sieht.
Okay, was soll der Kram nochmal kosten?
Ähm...
Wow!
120 Dollar, ne.
Nö.
Sixteen and a half feet.
Was ist denn das in einer ordentlichen Einheit?
Zu Zentimeter, okay.
Zu Meter? Fünf Meter.
Sixteen and a half feet.
Das sind typische Kokona-Einheiten, Alter, wieder.
Wie viel kostet ein HDMI-Kabel?
Fünf Euro fünfzig.
Okay, das ist dann aber kein,
das ist dann kein fünf Meter HDMI-Kabel.
Fünf Meter HDMI-Kabel ist vielleicht ein bisschen teurer,
vielleicht kostet es dann sieben Euro fünfzig
oder so.
Aber zur
Mindest eins muss man mal sagen,
das Produkt macht, was es soll,
und das ist das Wichtige.
Da kann sich jeder selbst überlegen,
wir können hier viel drüber philosophieren,
ob es einen Anwendungszweck gibt oder sonst was.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Die versprechen das und sie halten das.
Da kann man sich jetzt überlegen, ob man das kauft oder nicht.
Wenn man dann denkt, man bräuchte das, warum nicht?
Ich für meinen Teil sehe jetzt da wenig
Anwendungszweck daheim, aber
solange es draufsteht,
was sie können und sie
halten es dann auch, ist doch gut.
Beamer ist tatsächlich wirklich eine gute Idee,
falls man da kein Kabel hinlegen will.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Okay Leute, was sollte ich mir jetzt noch angucken?
Irgendwas zur Corona-App sollte ich mir angucken.
MonkaCorona.
Das ist nämlich relativ neu.
Das ist hier vorgestern.
Von vorgestern.
Comments are turned off. Oh!
Oh!
Die Verschwörungstheorie ist am Start wieder.
Bestimmt.
Gibt es einen Chat?
Zum Video? Ne, gibt keinen Chat.
Okay.
Ich habe sie nicht installiert.
Mein Handy kann das nicht.
Smartphone.
Was ist das für ein bescheuerter Vergleich?
So eine App in der Richtung gab es doch
vorher auch noch nicht.
Das sind also TAN-Nummern,
die man vielerorts eben noch braucht,
wenn man infiziert ist, einen positiven Corona-Test
hatte, um die dann auch, um das dann tatsächlich
so in der App zu hinterlegen. Und da sind
wir eigentlich auch schon beim ersten Problem.
Man muss das Ganze in vielen
Orten jetzt eben noch telefonisch machen.
720p?
Ist das euer Ernst?
...wirklich getestet wurde und kriegt dann diese Nummer.
Das ist alles sehr, sehr kompliziert. Das liegt daran, dass
viele Labore, viele Gesundheitsämter eben auch noch
nicht digital an die App angeschlossen sind.
Ja gut, wir sind ja auch in Deutschland im Jahr 2020.
Da kann man das ja auch nicht erwarten.
Das ist ja undenkbar.
Herr Neumann, ich freue mich,
dass Sie mir heute zugeschaltet sind.
Und da natürlich die allererste Frage.
Dieser digitale Anschluss der Labore
an diese App, wo ist da das
große Problem? Warum ist das noch nicht so weit?
Und wie schnell kann das gehen?
Das war auch Zero Latency gerade.
Ich denke, das hätte längst
fertiggestellt sein sollen, dieser Anschluss.
Wir sehen hier einfach einen Mangel
in einer sauberen Digitalisierung.
Das ist jetzt auch nichts Neues.
Insofern einerseits nicht verwunderlich,
andererseits aber natürlich
Das ist zu erwarten gewesen.
...errgerlich, denn das Ziel dieser App ist ja,
Warnungen möglichst schnell
auszusenden. Und wenn Leute nicht schnell
über ihre
Testergebnisse informiert werden,
dann können sie natürlich auch nicht schnell Leute informieren.
Zum Informieren dann noch
irgendwelche Telefonate zu führen, statt einfach
einen Button zu drücken. Das scheint im Moment
so eine Angezündung...
Wir können froh sein, dass die Ämter das nicht per Fax schicken.
Wobei...
Wahrscheinlich schicken die es per Fax.
Wenn ich so recht darüber nachdenke.
Wahrscheinlich ist es
noch per Fax. Wenn überhaupt.
Wir können froh sein, dass sie die noch anrufen müssen,
wenn es schon per Fax ist.
...Handbremse bei dieser App zu sein.
Und sie ist unnötig. Diese App selber
ermöglicht ja einfach ein sehr viel schnelleres Verfahren.
Das heißt, das Meldewesen...
Nutzt du dieses Addon? Ja.
Ja.
Nee. Ja, aber nicht für Edge.
Aber nicht für Edge.
Warum fragst du?
Hier hinterher.
Sie haben gerade gesagt, die App selber, das klingt ja so durch,
ist dann demnach auch hilfreich. Allerdings
wissen wir ja nur, wie oft sie heruntergeladen wurde.
Tatsächlich wissen wir gar nicht, wie viele Menschen informiert wurden,
dass sie mit einer Risikoperson Kontakt hatten,
weil es diese zentralen Daten
gar nicht gibt.
Ja, das ist doch sehr schön
und sehr gut. Ich denke, genau diese
Datensparsamkeit und
verteilte Datenhaltung
und der Datenschutz ist ja
der einzige Grund und das Einhorn,
warum immerhin 15,8 Millionen
Deutsche bisher diese App
heruntergeladen haben, wenn man nun ein System
hätte, wo all das zentral
erfasst ist, denke ich, hätte niemals
so viel Vertrauen. Ja, das stimmt.
Man muss ihn echt mal
zugutehalten. Sie haben sich diesmal
Mühe gegeben. Man kann sich jetzt streiten,
warum der Kram so extrem teuer war.
Man kann auch von Telekom
und SAP Geschiss halten, was man will.
Aber sowas gab es in der
Form noch nicht. Das Ding wurde, nachdem
sie ja vorher schon mit einem
App-Versuch komplett baden gegangen sind,
mit ihrem Open Source GitHub
Ansatz, finde ich echt
gut. Das sollten sie bei allen Sachen so machen.
Das würde viel mehr Vertrauen schaffen
in die
Technik.
Das würde viel mehr Vertrauen
in die Technik schaffen.
Wie gesagt,
ich kann jeden
verstehen, der da prinzipiell wenig
Vertrauen drin hat. Guckt man sich mal an,
von Gesundheitsakte bis
Bundestrojaner bis Personalausweis,
was es da nicht alles für Sachen
gibt, die total in die Hose gegangen sind.
Zumindest aus
Datenschutz-Sicht in die Hose gegangen sind.
Vielleicht auch aus funktionaler Sicht in die Hose
gegangen sind. Kann ich
jeden verstehen, der da kein großes Vertrauen drin hat.
Aber diesmal haben sie sich echt
Mühe gegeben. Das muss man ihnen mal zugutehalten.
Also, dass hier nicht
viele Daten erfasst werden können und nicht viele Statistiken
rausgegeben können, ist
ein Vorteil dieser App und nicht ein Nachteil. Ja.
Ja, und gerade das Thema
zentrale Datenspeicherung, dezentral, das ist ja
auch ein Thema bei der internationalen Vernetzung
der vorhandenen Corona-Warn-Apps. Und
darüber habe ich vor wenigen Minuten
auch mit Staatsministerin Moritz Werner gesprochen.
Hören wir mal rein, was sie dazu gesagt hat.
Da kommt es eben auf
die unterschiedlichen Ansätze an.
Ganz einfach auch
die Vernetzung mit den Ländern, die
ebenfalls diesen dezentralen Ansatz gewählt
haben. Schwerer ist es halt bei
Nachbarländern wie Frankreich, die sich für den
zentralen Ansatz entschieden haben. Es ist nicht
unmöglich, aber immerhin ist es schon
möglich, dass in allen EU-Staaten
einschließlich Norwegen, Großbritannien
und der Schweiz auch die App aus dem
App Store heruntergeladen werden kann, also
auch unsere App.
Ja, heißt die internationale Vernetzung,
die ist zwar ein bisschen schwierig, je nachdem,
ob die Daten zentral gespeichert werden oder nicht,
aber es ist auch nicht unmöglich, sagt Dorothee
Bär zurück zu Linus Neumann vom
Chaos Computer Club. Kann man das
einigermaßen vereinfacht darstellen, wo da die
Probleme liegen, wenn das eben verschiedene Ansätze sind?
Ach, das ist die für digitales
Spiel.
Stimmt, jetzt weiß ich, wer das ist.
Ich kann mir das mittlerweile echt nicht mehr merken,
wer da was ist.
Ich komm da nicht mehr mit.
Die meisten Leute sind auch so extrem
profillos irgendwie. Ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht
mehr merken, wer da was ist. Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Das ist die,
die nicht bei der
Gamescom beim
deutschen Computerspielepreis in diesem
komischen Kleid rumgerannt ist.
Die war das doch.
Die in diesem komischen, pinken Kleid
rumgewetzt ist.
Das Kernproblem liegt eigentlich immer nur darin,
ob ein Land dem anderen
vertraut, eine korrekte Meldung
abzugeben.
Also am meisten vertraue ich den Chinesen
über korrekte Meldungen.
... seinen Meldewesen noch nicht ganz im Griff hat,
dann können Sie sich vorstellen, wie das nun aussehen
würde, wenn Sie diesen Prozess
öffnen für
eventuell ganz Europa.
Das ist etwas, worüber
Einigkeit hergestellt werden muss.
Es gibt diesen einen dezentralen Ansatz,
der jetzt der de facto Standard ist.
Alle Länder, die etwas anderes machen,
das Beispiel Frankreich wurde gerade genannt,
verabschieden sich von diesem Standard
und damit auch von jeglicher
Möglichkeit einer internationalen
Interoperabilität.
Das hat er aber schön gesagt.
... Frankreich nicht teilnehmen können.
Sie müssten nur dann dort eben
die französische App benutzen.
Offiziell ist es aber möglich,
mit dem System von Apple und Google,
das ja nun bei den meisten Ländern
angewendet wird, einfach
eine Interoperabilität hinzubekommen,
dass ich beispielsweise mit der deutschen App
auch eine
Meldung in Italien abgeben kann.
Die Basis
dafür ist da, nur das
Meldewesen im Hintergrund muss jetzt quasi
von Apple, Google zusammen mit den Ländern
definiert werden. Aber der Standard
ermöglicht es. Nationale Alleingänge
waren noch nie
international interoperabel.
Also wie gesagt,
was das Melden der richtigen Zahlen angeht,
da traue ich am meisten den Chinesen,
weil da weißt du auf jeden Fall schon mal von vornherein,
es stimmt nicht. Da kannst du dich wenigstens auf eine Sache
verlassen. Da musst du erst gar nicht anfangen
zu rechnen. Du kannst davon ausgehen,
es ist eh verkehrt.
Und Google, Stichwort Betriebssystem, im Moment ist diese
Corona-Warn-App ja auch nur auf neuen Geräten
wegen den neuen Betriebssystemen
möglich. Man arbeitet daran, sagt zumindest
die Bundesregierung, das auch auf mehr Geräte auszuweiten.
Wie weit ist man da und
wo sind da die Haken?
Also wenn ein Telefon
diese App nicht unterstützt,
kann das zwei Gründe haben. Das eine ist,
dass die Hardware, also tatsächlich die im
Gerät verbauten Elemente
nicht dazu in der Lage sind.
Dann haben wir einfach, ist wirklich mit einem
Gerät zu tun, was technisch
nicht diesem modernen
Stand entspricht. Da kann man auch nichts tun.
Ein anderes Problem, und ich denke,
das viel größere Problem
ist, wenn wir Geräte haben, die zwar
technisch in der Lage sind,
aber von den Herstellern nicht mehr mit
Updates... Neues Testament, es ging nicht um
die App, glaube ich, es ging um das Übermitteln
von Diagnosen von
Ländern zu Ländern.
Also wenn jetzt irgendeine italienische
äh,
italienische App das
mitkriegt, sich da einer registriert oder so,
dass es dann rüberkommt zu uns irgendwie so.
...sehen werden.
Leider ist es ja so, dass wenn Sie
jetzt so ein Mobiltelefon bauen,
Sie hauptsächlich einfach mal
Kosten dafür haben, das zu produzieren.
Und dann einmal bezahlt werden, wenn Sie es
verkaufen. Und viele Hersteller entscheiden
eben im weiteren Verlauf in der Pflege
dieses Produktes, bei dem Bereitstellen
von Updates Geld zu sparen.
Das ist eine Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs,
dem quasi entgegenzuwirken,
indem Updates für einen bestimmten
Zeitraum verpflichtend werden.
Oh, das wäre gut.
Wird zwar nie passieren, aber
das fände ich auch gut.
...Haltbarkeitsdatum für Geräte,
denn es ist tatsächlich so, dass Sie heute
ein günstiges Mobiltelefon kaufen können,
für das Sie im Zweifelsfall
nie wieder Updates erhalten
und das schon veraltet
im Regal liegt, wenn Sie es kaufen.
Und ich denke, das ist nicht haltbar.
Erstens, weil wir sehen, dass hier technisch...
TV-Hawk, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Subscription.
...Geräte nicht auf den neuen Stand gebracht werden,
das wiederum auch Leute dazu zwingt, sich
wieder neue Geräte zu kaufen.
Das heißt, wir haben nicht nur ein Problem
im Konsumenten- und Datenschutz, sondern auch
ein ökologisches Problem, wenn
einwandfreie Geräte im Prinzip obsolet
gemacht werden, obwohl sie technisch
noch wunderbar funktionieren würden.
Ja, das wollen
die Hersteller im Endeffekt, ja.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir...
Also, ich habe mir ein Asus-Tablet
gekauft, ein Asus-Android-Tablet
mal, und die haben nicht einmal
ein ordentliches Update geliefert. Nicht einmal.
Es ist voll für den Arsch gewesen.
So, und was habe ich jetzt... Also, ich habe das für meine Mutter
gekauft, das Asus-Tablet. Was habe ich
danach gemacht? Ein iPad gekauft. Bäm.
Geht. Kriegt Updates und sonst was.
Und einfach zum Benutzen ist das
top.
Ja, diese Fehlermeldung
tritt auf Apple-Telefonen
auf und kommt tatsächlich
nicht von der App selber, sondern
vom Apple-Betriebssystem.
Also, diese App nutzt eine
Funktionalität, die in das
Apple-IOS-Betriebssystem eingebaut
wurde und diese Fehlermeldung kommt
tatsächlich dort her. Sie hat ein bisschen was
damit zu tun, dass das Telefon natürlich
weiß, dass in unterschiedlichen Ländern
potenziell unterschiedliche Apps
laufen und versucht, dem
irgendwie ein bisschen Rechnung zu tragen. Ich habe
gesehen, dass es heute Morgen ein neues Update
für das Apple-IOS-Betriebssystem gibt
und ich hoffe, dass
diese Fehlermeldung damit dann auch Geschichte
sein wird. Das ist sehr
ärgerlich, stört aber die App
nicht in ihrer Funktionalität. Es stört
aber natürlich die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer,
die von dieser Fehlermeldung teilweise mehrmals
am Tag behelligt werden. Ich hoffe,
dass das nun ein Ende
hat. Gleichzeitig ist zu sagen,
diese App und diese Funktionalität wurden
in relativ kurzer Zeit
programmiert und es ist bei jeder App
vollkommen normal und auch bei jeder
Betriebssystem-Erneuerung völlig
normal, dass es auch Fehler gibt.
Nein!
Ich habe jemals einen Bug gesehen bei
irgendwas, was ich on-stream programmiert habe.
Ist ausgeschlossen. Kann nicht sein.
Komplett bugfrei.
Immer.
Und auch völlig normal, dass die zügig behoben werden müssen.
Heute ist es einen Monat her und ich denke...
Nicht einmal, genau.
Ich hoffe, dass mit diesen Updates jetzt
die Fehlermeldung Geschichte sein wird.
Vielen Dank, Herr Neumann. Also
wir fassen noch einmal zusammen. Die
Corona-Warn-App, die ist jetzt seit einem Monat
am Start. Das ist dann jetzt auch wirklich
mal an der Zeit, dass einige kleine Bugs, die dann noch
von einigen Nutzern festgestellt werden,
behoben sind. Insgesamt, das sagt zumindest auch
der Chaos Computer Club, ist man aber mit
dem dezentralen Ansatz, der ja auch
die Daten schützen soll, der Nutzer zufrieden.
So, wie alt ist das Video? Das ist neu. Das ist
drei Tage alt. Warum das so eine schlechte
Bewertung hat, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil nicht darauf eingegangen wird, dass
äh...
Wuhan 5G und Bill Gates und ach was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Ich war beim Friseur,
beim Haareschneiden-Friseur, nicht bei dem Friseur.
Und die Mädels
da, die müssen ja auch Masken aufhaben.
Und die, die mir die Haare geschnitten hat,
hat die Maske über den Mund, aber nicht über
der Nase gehabt.
Ich hab mir auch gedacht, okay, irgendwie
entweder hat sie keinen Bock drauf
oder sie hat die Funktionsweise nicht genau
verstanden.
Äh, weil es eben
Diskussionen gab, Apple ist teurer. Also
gerade bei Tablets,
gerade bei Tablets ist es
nicht so. Wenn ihr euch ein ordentliches Android
Tablet kaufen wollt, ist das genauso teuer, wie
ein iPad. Wäre nicht sogar ein bisschen teurer,
wenn du dir eins kaufst, wo du auch auf jeden Fall Barbedales
kriegst.
Hat sie eine Brille? Nö.
Hat sie nicht.
Keine Brille.
Keine Brille und nix.
Sie sieht ausgesprochen
hübsch aus, muss man sagen, ja.
Aber das entbindet trotzdem keinen davon,
sich die Maske aufzusetzen.
Da muss man sich halt auch mal verunstalten,
ja. Da erkennt man es halt nicht,
dass man so hübsch ausschaut.
Ähm, genauso wie die eine
auf Facebook, die diesen
Werbepost für ihre Facemask
gemacht hat, die
Löcher drinne hatte.
Wo sie gesagt hat, wo sie geschrieben haben,
das würde die feminine Seite besonders hervorheben.
Und da hat sie jetzt halt so eine Maske
mit Löchern drin. Das ist komplett Fail.
Also manchmal glaube ich, die Leute sind einfach
zu, zu
low brain.
Lost, genau. Komplett lost.
So.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass die
meisten, also ja, die meisten Leute sind dumm.
Aber dafür sind sie nicht zu dumm.
Also den Zusammenhang
zwischen
Maske
über Mund und Nase und das,
wenn es nicht über Nase ist,
den Zusammenhang können die meisten Leute schon erfassen.
Da brauchst du ja einen IQ von unter
70 wahrscheinlich, dass du das nett kapierst.
Also das ist schon
echt low.
Aber das,
die sind entweder hirnlos,
die denken einfach nicht dran
oder sie machen das absichtlich.
Genau, das interessiert
die nicht mehr.
Da hast du bestimmt einige.
Ja, ich hab ja auch die gleiche
Playlist vom letzten Mal wieder angemacht.
So Leute, ich hab übertrieben
Hunger. Ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Ähm.
Mal gucken.
Ob ich vielleicht später nochmal
onkomme.
Ich schau mal gerade, ob wir
irgendjemanden haben, den wir hosten können.
Und zwar,
wen können wir denn hosten?
Irgendwissen was kleineres, dem ich auch
folge, der es verdient hat
und wo es auch was bringt.
Weil irgendwelche 5000 sonst was
Zuschauer Channels muss ich nicht hosten.
Die haben schon genug.
Nö, keiner da.
Nö.
Welche Event Streams stehen bald an?
Also es gab ja letztens
einen über den
Playstation 5 Controller und der war
Hyper Resident Sleeper. Langweilig.
Xbox kommt
genau. Xbox kommt jetzt.
Demnächst.
Wann ist denn das?
CEST
6pm
Gibt es das vielleicht auch in normalen Zeiten?
18 Uhr. Okay.
18 Uhr.
23. Events.
Wo habe ich es denn?
Ja. Ah, da haben wir es doch schon.
Haben wir es doch sogar schon eingetragen.
Lull.
Genau Luke, wir haben jetzt gelernt,
immer schön dankbar sein.
Dann lebt man glücklicher.
Ja.
War nicht
E3. Ne, E3 ist dieses Jahr ausgefallen.
Die haben nur ein paar
Pressekonferenzen gemacht
zu der gleichen Zeit.
Exzellent Musik.
Was? Hier sind alle Events aufgelistet.
Ja ey, das war so mega
langweilig. Das war so
extrem langweilig.
Ja, das war es.
Passende Outromusik würde ich sagen.
So Chat, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich gehe mal was essen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.